the purchase begun as many of you know I
mentioned this uh on Twitter and the
other day we had two videos taken down
from YouTube one was a a clip about Matt
Walsh's response to it an employee that
was terminated the other was the entire
episode we had recently done with
Brandon strzok we don't know exactly why
it was taken down I wasn't uh yet given
a reason or at least uh I don't know
maybe maybe got lost in the junk mail
but they haven't said anything to me
other than it's been removed and you
will not receive a strike we're hearing
that a bunch of other people have
experienced something similar uh Jeremy
boring of the daily wire said that Matt
Walsh had been demonetized so it looks
like The Purge hath begun and it may
have something to do with transgender
ideology the Bud Light controversy and
Dylan Mulvaney so we'll talk about that
the quartering and Sydney Watson had a
video video removed and interestingly
enough the video that the quartering had
removed this is Jeremy Hambly apparently
was criticizing Matt Walsh for being too
mean to Dylan Mulvaney so I'll show you
his tweets and then we'll talk about
that censorship
so it's a it's a fairly crazy day in
terms of uh that ongoing censorship but
uh before we get started my friends head
over to castbrew.com we are our own
sponsor so that's right go to Castro
pick up cast brew coffee will ship by
May 5th it's a pre-order cast brew
coffee is our company you can get your
rise with Roberto Jr breakfast blender
your Appalachian nights as well as
Colombian or French roast if you'd like
to support the show you can just uh buy
from us when you want to get your coffee
once we launch formally we're going to
create a subscription service so you can
just you know regularly get your coffee
delivered and all that stuff and a bunch
of other cool stuff pertaining to the
launching of a physical coffee shop
we are doing uh um well I'll keep it a
little vague because I don't want to say
too much but construction and uh fitting
and plumbing work is is currently
underway and so we're hoping that will
be set up soon but also become a member
at timcast.com by clicking join us go to
timps.com sign up support our work
directly and you'll get access to the
Discord server where you can hang out
with like-minded individuals and uh talk
with them about uh life and stuff if
you've been a member for at least six
months or you sign up at 25 bucks you
can actually call in to the members only
uncensored show Monday through Thursday
at 11 PM submit questions and
potentially be one of our regular
callers that we have during that segment
it's really exciting good fun so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Liz wheeler hey
thanks so much for having me I
appreciate it absolutely who are you
what do you do yeah my name is Liz
wheeler I host the Liz wheeler show uh
YouTube working cable news but now I own
a media company I host a podcast that
you can find at lizwehler.com or
anywhere that you listen to your pods or
watch your pods a little censored on
YouTube right now just like the rest of
us you can go to rumble.com Liz wheeler
um you had a video taken down as well
yeah yeah same topic same topic yeah we
had two I think this happened not last
night but the night before related to
Nashville and related to related to the
the Dylan stuff
um don't want to be too specific here
uh I mean we're gonna talk about it so
yeah I mean it's it's it's not
surprising right we we try to be pretty
careful on YouTube honestly because we
want to be there we want to be present
on YouTube but
um they're gonna find a way it's
actually funny so our Channel had gotten
demonetized maybe six months ago for
similar stuff and we had finally been
able to our strikes had run out and we
finally been able to reapply from uh
monetization and they had told us when
we reapplied like okay we'll evaluate
you within a month and it was literally
like the Midnight Hour it was like the
day that we that we were able that that
month was up so we were going to get our
our monetization back and it was that
day that they they took those videos
down and gave us a strike so I don't
think it's a coincidence but it is what
it is you expect this we'd like to use
the platform but it's not we don't rely
on it from business model yeah all right
we'll talk about that thanks for hanging
out we got Hannah Claire bremelo hi I'm
Hannah Claire brimwell I'm a writer for
timcast.com and I'm Ian Crossland very
happy to be here good to see you Liz hey
what's up everybody it's Kellen good to
be here uh happy Friday let's get
started dude nice mustache mustache I
think the lights are a little bright you
wanna well I'll start the segment you
want to dim the lights just a little bit
as we do this all right everybody we got
this first story here from uh the
quartering this is Jeremy Hambly and
I'll show you a few of these uh stories
Jeremy tweeted six hours ago this is
some bull-ish it says the video has been
removed for violating YouTube's policy
on harassment and bullying he says this
is an escalation of something I've been
noticing in analytics this is why the
Publican now was started I'll make a
video now but consider joining today and
then he says it was a video where I
defended Dylan Mulvaney much to the
Chagrin of many for how mean Matt Walsh
was to him I now regret that and then we
have uh this from Sydney Watson it says
YouTube has deleted an entire video from
the quartering and my community
community notes channel for bullying and
harassment we have to assume it's
because we discussed Dylan Mulvaney this
is exactly why we created the public a
noun and why we are so appreciative of
everyone who has signed up as a member
to support worth the effort gender
ideology is a Scourge it's asinine we
can't call it out
so I can only imagine this will continue
to get worse in terms of The Purge and
uh Liz you you were just mentioning you
had videos taken down as well yeah yeah
I did and it was about these same topics
like I said I'm not surprised here I
don't think any of us think of ourselves
as victims here but it is quite
something to see the censorship and what
discussion the left and these these
these corporate overlords don't want us
to be having does it ever resemble what
you experience working in cable you
should do a cable TV TV show right I did
no it's it's pretty different in a cable
news setting I had actually a tremendous
amount of freedom and didn't really have
restrictions on what I could say it was
before it was largely before a lot of
the transgender conversations it's funny
actually a little detour here there was
a video of mine that that went viral it
was from five or six years ago when I
was talking about like what's the
limiting principle so when Tommy Lee
posted
um and it I was talking about well
what's the limiting principle on
transgender
this video went pretty viral even though
it was from a few years ago and I
remember the day that I made that
because the crew that day were like okay
that's a little hyperbolic don't you
think and it's all happening now
um but at the time there wasn't the
censorship because The Descent against
it was just not quite hadn't quite
ramped up hadn't built up to the point
that we're at now
um so very different very different to
be independent it's fun to be
independent it's fun to own your own
company and to build your own to build
your own thing it does make it trickier
from a business aspect when you have to
dodge these kind of bullets but I care
less about the business aspect of it and
more about like the mission at part of
it we talk about this stuff because we
care about these people right not
necessarily not because it's good clicks
I think this may have something to do
with Anheuser-Busch the uh the removal
of the content and it's a convenient
scapegoat for YouTube to go after
um like harassment and bullying because
it's clearly related to Matt Walsh Dylan
Mulvaney these are these are some of the
the issues surrounding the
the video that Matt Walsh uh which
triggered it all was when he was
critical of Dylan Mulvaney which
resulted in people responding saying you
maybe pushed it too far Matt you were a
little mean but that's all he was he was
mean to a person and I think the issue
is
well let me put it this way
YouTube didn't say anything
this story came and went this was months
ago the story came and went but only now
that the Anheuser-Busch hit has extended
into now I think we're going to be
entering soon a fourth week this is the
end of I think the third week of
Anheuser-Busch boycott getting worse new
reporting that their sales are
continuing to drop there they've started
doing I've started getting ads from
Budweiser for the first time ever and so
what I think is happening is my personal
opinion here is that Anheuser-Busch
contacted YouTube and said it's your
fault and if you don't take this down we
will stop advertising With You YouTube
then says okay what do we do there are
big advertisers the biggest beer brand
in the world let's start removing these
videos I'm willing to bet Anheuser-Busch
went to YouTube a while ago and again
just my personal opinion I don't have
any Insider information or anything like
that I bet they went to YouTube and said
we spend too much money on your platform
to have to deal with all of these
channels using that platform to hurt us
so we're going to stop buying from you
it probably took YouTube a little while
to come up with a plan so this this to
me I think Anheuser-Busch probably went
to YouTube a week and a half ago saying
look at all these videos we're spending
X dollars but all these videos keep
coming out so YouTube probably came with
the policy they probably a discussion
where they said look if we ban these
videos and give strikes we're gonna lose
way more money the the videos don't
break the rules you know how I know they
don't break the rules YouTube did not
give strikes to any of these channels
that's very weird this first time I've
heard of that so when we got two videos
taken down they say we're just removing
them but you're not getting a strike we
got a strike I think you got a strike
yeah we gotta strike so uh I think
Jeremy said he didn't get a strike
either right I don't know that they just
removed it oh actually I have to I'm
gonna double check but I'm pretty sure
we got a strike look look here's here's
what Sydney Watson posted it says we
want to let you know our team reviewed
your content and we think it violates
our harassment policy we know you may
not have real lives was a violation of
our policy so we're not applying a
strike to your channel what that says to
me again in my personal opinion is that
they know it doesn't really break the
rules and if they apply a strike they
will lose more money the verbiage is we
think you violated it like it should
just say if we think it violates our we
think it did I think but we don't know
you didn't know it's illegal protection
yeah I understand mine says we think I'm
looking it up right now it says we think
it violates so we're going to approach
no we did get a strike it says we think
the notice so the email that I got
that's what I have a copy of right here
can you read that paragraph yeah says
our team has reviewed your content
unfortunately we think it violates our
hate speech policy we removed the
following content from YouTube we got
two emails oh no my team just texted me
we definitely got a strike oh wow but
they're saying hate speech and yours
yeah they defined hate speech and they
said we got an email that said exactly
the phrase that I used that they
consider to be hate speech well don't
say yeah
why is yours hate speech and this one is
harassment different things were said
but but here's by the way it's not hate
speech like what it's a bad term these
days that's really freaky this is
important though
here's here's why I think this YouTube
probably sat down and said if we apply a
strike to timcast IRL how much money do
we lose all of it we would leave the
network I mean it's not it's not just
the advertising it's not just the super
chats it's that the consistently highest
viewed uh like nightly show on YouTube
will immediately switch to rumble so
we're going to lose long-term Revenue
we're going to lose market share we're
gonna lose direct advertising what can
we do Budweiser Anheuser bush is furious
and we're going to lose their ads how
about we just take those videos down
from all these channels and then just
sweep it under the rug and don't apply
the strikes where we where we can avoid
applying strikes if you give a live show
a strike there's no live show so that's
why I think they're like okay let's just
take them down and not do a strike
because we want to make money this says
to me strictly about advertising and I
think Anheuser-Busch behind the scenes
is screaming but they know they can't
say things publicly they have dumped
money into this ad about this this
Clydesdale running streets or whatever
and it's because they did this after 9
11 and everybody loved it the Clyde's
day after 9 11 was a big deal they're
trying to do it again they are desperate
their sales are apparently down like 10
in the first two days of the boycott so
we have not yet gotten the data from
Anheuser-Busch on the past couple of
weeks but I bet it's so bad they went to
YouTube and said why should we advertise
with you when you keep publishing the
smears against us
when you're navigating these
conversations in my experience like
transgenderism for instance which isn't
it's a very important conversation for
everybody people that are transgender
that aren't transgender people we need
to communicate and find some common
ground there's you go the route of
talking you know systemically about
transgenderism and what you know body
dysmorphia and things like that then
there's that's one path then the other
path is you talk about
sexualizing children which is a
completely different conversation you
could be a straight person that's doing
it a transgender person that's doing it
that's another conversation when
children are involved then there's a
third part of it which is targeting
people like how Dylan got his name
brought up and I'm not I I like I mean
whatever I let you know Dylan you know
but when people bring up specific people
over and over again then it starts to be
like dog piling and they're like you
could consider harassment I'm sorry can
you harass the president by criticizing
things they do publicly it's also not an
individual I mean obviously Dylan is an
individual person but he's also a very
very influential
um activist political activist and
public figure right I mean there's
certain not just public figure but an
actual political activist who went to
the White House to try to get policy
passed about what state right but what
I'm saying is libel law is different for
public figure
so you know I think because we have
access to the internet and potentially
going viral basically in our pocket at
all times with our phones people forget
that you are electing to become a public
figure and therefore you are losing
someone of your legal protections and
the squeaky wheel gets the grease but I
think I think this is more
Anheuser-Busch and the evidence of that
is there's been conversation around
Dylan mulvanio's 11 million followers
for a very long time over a year that's
the you know we're on uh day year two of
the days of girlhood saga that Dylan
mulvania has produced you did didn't
care until Anheuser-Busch a major
Advertiser started getting hit in the
market share and losing sales so it
there actually is a reasonable business
like capitalist response and as a bush
might have just been like we're not
telling you YouTube like they might have
been like YouTube we're not telling you
to do anything we're just pointing out
there's really no reason for us to
advertise on your platform everybody
hates us there so bye it could be more
than in bed because Dylan has uh
marketing sponsorships with lots of
different companies Crest uh CeraVe EOS
they may have but but his agent may have
gone to all his people and be like let's
do a combined uh communication with
YouTube that we will all leave the
network like Crest would leave Budweiser
would leave and so YouTube's like well
what choice
wonder who is uh backing his his legal
defense fund right because I can imagine
just like Anheuser-Busch would go after
YouTube I assume Dylan also has a legal
team that's trying to get it and also
this is possible don't forget about the
corporate equality index you know that
that organization that's from the human
rights Rights Campaign that goes around
it's part of like the ESG metrics but
it's specifically focused on ranking
whether these big corporations are lgbtq
friendly quote unquote places to work
and they send representatives to these
corporations to make sure not just not
just for uh privileges or actual
workplace environment but whether these
corporations are doing advertising
campaigns that are specifically quote
unquote inclusive of transgender people
so I think that there's a lot of power
right now behind
um behind making sure that
Anheuser-Busch doesn't back down
especially as they're realizing that
this boycott is real a lot of
conservative boycotts yeah and Ezra Bush
apologizes yes yes because maybe I mean
I don't think they probably would have
but I think that they underestimated the
strength of this boycott because a lot
of conservative boycotts in the past
have been like fleeting they haven't
been incredibly effective
um because a lot of people don't agree
but this one's very effective but it
goes beyond this because uh and I'll
throw to Jesse Kelly I mentioned I cited
him several times he said it's the first
time his neighbors asked him about
politics yeah
yeah actually heard surprisingly you try
to talk to people about politics you
know how it goes they're gonna be like
oh you're talking about now I'm out and
people are like oh that Bud Light thing
and they they know about it check this
out it gets worse we got the story from
the Daily Mail Joe Rogan slams Bud
Lights Pro America commercial release
after partnership with Don Mulvaney I've
heard backfired and Warren's firm we
don't know who you really are he said
what did he say we don't know you really
are here's another quote in here I want
to make sure I read it they bury it he
says uh commenting it's like the effing
dumbest pro-america rah-rah like we
don't know who you really are now it's
so stupid and cliche it hurts my
feelings it's so dumb this is a company
in deep ish that was great that's from
the episode with Jim Brewer the biggest
podcast in the world and Joe Rogan at
first was like oh who cares about this
and then Budweiser played this stupid
and azer Bush played the stupid play and
then Joe was like what are you doing
yeah you actually said it would be way
funnier in the middle of the Clydesdale
running and everything that Dylan came
out and like was like Hey and like that
would have been amazing that would have
been hilarious serious they needed to
either shut up or like they could double
down shut up or apologize but they're
doing this weird let's try and Pander
the people who are currently really
angry with us it's showing how much
they're in chaos right like people are
saying Dil mavini's been dark for two
weeks it hasn't posted anything like
that's a very normal PR strategy just
say nothing until it dies and Anheuser
bus Budweiser they're like it's not the
worst of all of them and this is why I
think YouTube is starting to knock
videos down because when the pr 101
doesn't work you go Brute Force yeah
they go to YouTube and say ban the
morels and YouTube is like let's start
using Force against these people and
start striking them if they have
conversations we don't like I found it
insulting like I would consider myself
in the demographic that would buy Bud
Light I don't I don't drink it myself
like my husband would right and when I
saw this pro-american ad I thought well
that's a beautiful cinematic like
artistic piece of work right like who
doesn't feel kind of the raw raw
American seeing an ad like that and
afterward I was like how dare they try
to Pander to me how dare they try to
pacify me with that ad don't pretend to
hold these views when you've taught when
you've shown us what you really what you
really think of us and what you really
want for our country with a much larger
partnership with someone whose ideology
is very much opposed to you know these
these Traditional Values that you're
putting in this ad I it's missing like
the the self like knowledge you need to
see these companies self be self-aware
if you want to for them to buy their
products and trust them like don't just
pretend like it didn't happen and then
do a binary opposite it's in some ways
more insulting right because they're
taking this moment that was very
powerful back in the day and saying like
we'll just throw out here because
that'll make you guys shut up and that
will make you guys comply with what we
want the whole thing I don't care if
Dylan has a beer ad I find 21 year old
actor wants to sell beer go for it buddy
a month and a half ago he was wearing
little girl's dress called Eloise this
girl and pretending to be a little girl
and then a month later was selling beer
I'm like that's where I'm starting to be
right when you sell to kids because
that's like little kids Dylan Mulvaney's
audience is so again the data we know
for sure Tick Tock audience according to
various reports is on average below 21
which could mean 19 or 20. still not of
legal drinking age and you can make
arguments about college I personally
think the drinking age should be 18
because you're an adult and the
government shouldn't set arbitrary
standards like that but uh I'm not okay
with the targeting of children to drink
alcohol when you consider that don't
mulberry's audience is probably much
younger than that Del Mulvaney's
audience is probably not 20 years old
especially not 21. don't move in his
audience it's tick tock it's going to be
closer to 14 15. that's my opinion
you're saying that they knew what they
were doing they knew it would create a
firestorm like this no no they want to
Target dumb drinkers according to the
marketing the the VP said we need like
I'll just put it this way the left
response from personalities was that
they need to Target younger people to
get a new drinking audience and so they
don't want to be your dad's beer they
want to be your teenage daughter's beer
right so they're going after people who
aren't I mean this is cigarettes all
over again cigarettes get them while
they're young get them hooked for life
and so they're like drink beer kids and
it's like no don't do that don't
advertise the alcohol to Children your
demographic should be adults there
there's a Bud Light commercial with
Miles Teller whatever and it's like him
and his wife on hold and it's kind of
goofy but it's targeting adults who are
in their living room and they're waiting
for some adultly thing clearly intended
to Target someone who's in their mid to
late 20s or early 20s and I'm like
that's fine you know he he grabs two
lights out of the fridge and he cracks
them and then he dances over and they're
dancing to on hold music or whatever and
I'm like sure fine but the sickening
reality in man is that college students
have probably made Budweiser so much
money from underage drinking but but
hold on and everyone knows it and people
are like well we can't say it out loud
because it's illegal to sell to them
under 21 but the drinking age should be
18. but it's so hard on the brain but
yeah I agree I think drinking's bad but
I'm also not about to tell people like
how to live their lives and if you can
listen to the military you should be
able to drink a beer seriously and and
what's happened with the drinking age is
that there's actually been a lot of
teenagers who are at College 19 20 years
old of legal age to to enter to
contracts and join the military they get
drunk and then they don't call
paramedics because they're like oh that
happened to a girl I knew she had
alcohol poisoning yeah actually we she
did get taken to the hospital thank God
and she survived there are campuses that
have specific like if you call us you
will not get in trouble of rules because
this is such a problem there was a huge
Coalition of college presidents led by
the president of Dartmouth saying
binge drinking is such a problem we need
to lower the drinking age because you
need to be with your parents at home
when you're first being introduced to
alcohol and then you learn to drink
responsibly as opposed to this culture
that's like I need to get wasted before
I go to the bar because I may not be
able to drink again and I want to be
that's what they do in Europe and like
your drinking age is like a lot lower in
Europe no that's what I mean that's what
I mean like the drinking age is lower
and it's not it's graduated they'll say
yeah you're at this age hard liquor at
this yeah like a little watered down
wine at a special occasion it's not
quite so um like off limits yeah people
don't well we like
it's it's not a one-on-one correlation
but kids are allowed to have wine in
church not like you're guzzling it but
in Texas you can drink uh at the age of
16 if your parent is present yeah in
Wisconsin too I think there are a couple
states that have that culture where
again like if you are at a restaurant
with your parent you might be able to
drink I don't know the legality but we
create a culture that teaches people to
drink responsibly as opposed to see it
as a substance that you're not going to
be able to get so you might as well
basically kill yourself this this is a
this is a good one we should read this
it says uh an opinion piece in uh
published in Bloomberg last week
described the move by Bud Light as
setting a new low in corporate courage
quote kicking a political hornet's nest
for collects and Giggles before running
away is no way to elevate a brand or
promote a cause wrote Ben schlot the
Publications advertising and Brands
columnist like I think the important
thing to point out is that y'all
actually had Joe Rogan the first week
then you doubled down in this weird way
and now Joe Rogan is he's in The Fray
and he's like okay this is really stupid
now they let some young active marketing
VP make the weird you know sell the beer
to Dylan sell the beer to his audience
and then they realize oops and then
probably what happened was like the CEO
of the company's like we're doing what
we used to do make get the horse we got
to open the stable get the horse should
it just come out and been like Hey we're
sorry for sponsoring this influencer we
weren't aware that it would trigger such
a divisive reaction we won't we won't do
it again or lean into it so hard and I
mean you know one way or the other but
did you see that did you see the CEO's
statement though right after I think
that that's what primed me for being
like insulted by the video is he
released this statement and he's like we
didn't mean to step into such a
controversial issue and I was like do
you live under a rock like do you not
realize that that choosing this
political activist based on the identity
is going to spark an enormous enormous
controversy I was like you you had to
know I don't believe that I don't
believe the reports that say that oh
this was a rogue employee or this wasn't
approved like no someone in a
decision-making power at a corporation
like that knew about this I I say it
like this it would be no different
politically if they sponsored Alex Jones
it's not that Dylan Mulvaney is is just
trans some people don't like or I don't
think Donald Mulvaney actually is trans
I think Dylan Mulvaney is actually
insulting and hurting trans people but
that's a separate issue if they if if
Dylan Mulvaney is a hyperpolarizing
figure who is either despised or beloved
Alex Jones very similar absolutely
despised by the left beloved by the
right Bud Light probably shouldn't be
entering The Fray in politics to this
degree with these kinds of personalities
and I really I agree I think they knew
exactly what was going to happen it's
possible that some people didn't which
is equal it's freaky to me but what I
mean is I don't think they expected this
level of chaos I think they they thought
they were going to get a ton of
attention and right they couldn't stop
it in a second though this I was saying
this I was saying this on my show the
other day I said they underestimate how
forgiving conservatives are because we
are we're not the ones that engage in
cancel culture right we just want we
just in this case don't want to to vote
with our money we're not saying oh we're
going to write you off for life if they
came out and said hey please forgive us
we're sorry we won't do this again we
realize that it's not in alignment with
what our values have been and what your
values are
um then every we would all be like okay
no problem like we actually forgive you
if you if you truly repent but the fact
that their CEO was just like we didn't
know that we were being this way but I I
I want to clarify that people on the
culture War right post-liberals
libertarian Etc absolutely should
boycott companies and refuse to to
partake in their products that's not
cancel culture I agree cancel culture is
when you went hey Budweiser we just
found out that 20 years ago you made a
commercial that had an American flag in
it so we are boycotting your product
cancel culture is when you go to
someone's past I agree that's what I'm
saying conservatives are forgiving this
isn't cancel culture this is just
momentary consequences for their
behavior and so it's not it's not a
forever thing like I would never at this
point I would I plan never to buy
anything Anheuser-Busch ever again but
if they come out and apologize for it
I'd be like okay sure yeah
it's in Austin if they came out that
Friday and said we're really sorry for
sponsoring this individual we did not
realize how divisive this would turn out
to be we won't do it again we we respect
and you know love all of our customers
and those who enjoy Bud Light let's get
back to just having beers with each
other and not you know being politically
divisive we're sorry I would have got up
on stage and I would have yelled ooh Bud
light's for everybody on the house I'm
buying do you think it immediately went
out and I don't even drink do you think
they're afraid of the backlash from the
other side of this like if you said be
Goldberg threatened them right and if
you say like we won't do this we won't
ever do this again like what are you
saying are you saying you won't have a
trans person are you saying you won't
have someone whose audience primarily
teenagers are you saying it's part of
the like I think so many of these issues
are Dylan Mulvaney again yeah but is
that enough like is is that going to
seem like a direct threat to the other
side of the aisle well I I don't care I
mean the other side of the aisle 20 year
old at 20 year olds and teenagers aren't
buying Bud Light so they've decided to
alienate their entire Market in an
effort to attract teenagers that you you
what yeah this is what I said you have
the ages of 21 to 80. okay where you're
marketing beer to these people at
barbecues at picnics at sporting events
and they said the win actually came out
made a video where she was like we need
a new younger audience and it's like
you're at best targeting 21 to 24 year
olds so you're going to take those three
years over the entire human lifespan
that you're sacrificing your entire
doesn't make sense you're talking a
little bit like a businessman that knows
more than I think that the
Anheuser-Busch people know because
you're looking at it just from a revenue
like marketing standpoint I think
there's more at play than just making a
business decision impact investment yeah
I think that the ESG stuff like you
behind the scenes they're getting
incredible pressure especially because
they have been somewhat of a patriotic
company or tried to appeal to patriotic
people in the past like they're getting
incredible pressure from these ESG
systems now these ESG metrics to be woke
not just environmentally but on social
issues that's why we saw those companies
like paying for their employees to go to
different states for abortions like
announcing they were going to do that
because that's being a good corporate
citizen that's crazy right it's super
crazy and that's the same with this I
mean I think this plays into it
the woman asks for a maternity leave and
they're like no but we'll fly you there
to abort the baby yeah like like we
won't give you time off we won't give
you any extra money you can't have the
kid it just literally makes it better
for us to keep you as a worker be what's
the woman that's really what it is the
the cost of maternity leave for a
corporation is greater than the cost of
the abortion so these these corporations
were offering to pay for women to travel
out of state to get an abortion because
it saves them money in the long run
that's that's insane because they really
care about me it's because they want me
to be happy they want you to be a CEO
get out of your chair Tim I'm moving in
uh no but I do think that with
Anheuser-Busch I'd be really curious to
know what the internal conversations are
like right like I think you're right
there are a lot of outside organizations
that will Lobby and pressure them but I
would also like to know what the culture
is among employees like have they been
specifically recruiting you know
Progressive lgbtq people who are saying
if you say that you won't sponsor Dylan
MLB again we will you know turn on you
well I don't know what employees do at
beer companies but you know become
incredibly difficult they must be
getting a lot of very strange pressure
from a lot of different directions this
was Alyssa Heiner's shade is the the
woman who made the call on this whole
this whole ad campaign and she said in
her in her initial in that video where
she was talking about that it was about
inclusivity and we want to be inclusive
and then she said repeated it so like
what does this word even mean if you're
using it multiple times but that was the
it's like brain what kind of like this
brainwashing of like but before we move
on I want to mention one more thing well
we may have breaking news so uh before
we go into whatever that was uh you may
want to mention it we have this tweet
from clay Travis someone actually just
super chatted clay Travis tweets Bud
Light has fired the marketing VP who
green lit the Dylan Mulvaney
advertisement I'm not going to read what
he said uh as the brand sales continue
to tank that's Alyssa that's the woman I
was just talking about is she is she the
one that criticized uh Bud light's brand
for being too fratty but then that other
video of her surface being kind of
Friday yes it was 20 years ago about her
job this girl doesn't even like the
company she works for good question why
why are people like that getting jobs
and making calls like this
this girl who doesn't seem to like it
here is the future of our marketing face
I'm also surprised she didn't get fired
sooner but that's how we don't they are
really struggling it's play Travis is
tweeting it we'll see if we get more
confirmation on that so I wanted to
clarify that there's a difference
between boycotting and canceling in no
way has this become a cancel movement
against uh Budweiser this is a boycott
against Budweiser canceling is when you
say don't let them on that platform
boycott is when you say everyone mute
that account that's different you can
you can ignore ignore corporations
that's boycotting them but when you when
you demand that they're not allowed to
participate that's when you're
attempting to cancel that's you don't
want to cancel that's the bad stuff I
disagree boycott all you want that's
Market Force but I don't like cancel
method I think yeah we should we should
cancel absolutely free speech dude it's
not canceling you you misunderstand
canceling always is a reference to you
had um Sarah Silverman got fired from a
job because 10 years prior she made a
blackface joke that's canceling someone
it's like you were a bad person a long
time ago and you are being excised
that's what we were all complaining like
are you kidding like that guy made a
joke and then you know Mike cernovich
came out and and pointed out that James
Gunn had made off-color jokes 10 years
prior and then he got booted temporarily
that was cancel culture
the left saying something like hey this
company supports this guy currently
right now we don't like that we're
boycotting is just a boycott the right
saying Bud Light sponsored someone we
don't like that's a boycott we need to
be saying to these companies we will not
give you money if you're doing things
that are bad that's boycotting say I I
won't I won't give you the things but
saying Twitter don't let Budweiser on
your platform anymore that's a cancel
move that's that's the wrong way oh well
I don't think anybody's doing that
though no no they're not this is all
about what do you what do you call when
because I agree the clarification but I
think there's a third element of it too
and that's the de-platforming one is so
when social media companies like what
they try to do to president Trump on um
Facebook on Twitter on Instagram where
they they called his words violence or
whatever they called it and then they
kicked him off in an attempt to act to
like cancel him that's also cancel
culture not just based on something they
dug up but based on the fact that they
are trying to perfectly silence and I
think cancel culture can go even more
extreme right you know of people who
lose their bank accounts they're not
allowed to use PayPal like they are
unpersoned from things that interact
with the Internet or in some way connect
to social media or basically make it
possible to exist in society right like
that's cancel culture at the extreme I
think saying like I won't buy a product
that's a boycott right saying I'm gonna
block this person that's not canceling
them
but like cancel culture has become such
a normal that it naturally has ramped up
and can become incredibly interest for
me cancel culture is the unpersoning of
someone making it so they basically
cannot exist in mainstream Society yeah
it's a violation of the equality of
opportunity yeah it's it's a it's a
smear on the United States and
everything it stands for yeah versus
boycotting is saying you can be in the
market but I'm I don't want to do a a
market-based transaction with you and I
will encourage 100 million people to
also not do it yeah and I liked what you
said before I mean I think it's true
conservative sort of lack Direction in
boycotts I think they are quick to
forgive and sometimes I think that's
part of uh the the Thematic Christianity
that follows a lot of conservatives uh
conservatives they believe that if you
repent you should you deserve forget
giveness but really people say I'm sorry
and keep doing the bad thing we have
confirmation uh from at age Bud light's
marketing leadership undergoes shake-up
after Dylan Mulvaney controversy Alyssa
heinershide who has led the brand since
June takes a leave of absence and is
replaced by Budweiser Global Marketing
VP Todd Allen so not fired leave of
absence
wow this is this is a huge move on the
part of anheuser-bit Anheuser-Busch add
age of course for everybody wondering is
newsguard certified 100 out of 100 this
is hard confirmation that this woman has
been temporarily removed from her
position this means it is 100 times
worse than what you think it is it looks
like they brought in the big with the
big guy Global Marketing VP I guess
would be far superior to Alyssa who was
like uh just the U.S domestic oh boy
you're just not going to be happy about
this one you see and this is my point
there is no way they made a move this
bold because you know when you're
working in corporate and you've got
marketing people and PR people they're
gonna say you do this it is dropping a
boulder in a lake it is going to Ripple
out everyone's going to be talking about
it you are reigniting the story but they
knew they had to do it yeah that's how
bad it was what is that says to me it is
extremely likely as I believed as I
mentioned earlier as I believe that they
went to YouTube and said take these
videos down or else what if it was a
coordinated effort and they were like
listen for our business we have to fire
the people that did this or we're not
going to recover our Revenue but at the
same time we want to serve this leftist
agenda or our ESG score so how about you
remove all the criticism of Dylan
Mulvaney we remove our marketing team
and it like evens out I don't that makes
no sense like there's there's no
strategy here what the the fact that
they are removing this woman she's
taking a leave of absence maybe it was
of her own Coalition but not apologizing
says a lot which is where you're
probably right that they don't want to
besmirch the the good name of ESG right
but they know they're reeling from it
and it all right so they're in the two
moves maybe if they did if they did
pressure YouTube at the same time to be
like hey we're gonna if you don't remove
this stuff and then also this then they
can be like well we did both we're
serving both yeah man it would have been
way easier oh I'm sorry oh no it's
excited to be interesting if she quietly
comes back you know she's going to leave
absence right Terminator or like in six
months when they think this come down
because you're completely right Tim like
their sales are hurting and it's the
beginning of the second quarter of the
year like they need to uh fix this as
quickly as possible so it doesn't carry
in I mean I can only imagine that summer
is a pretty intense sales uh time for a
year right like they don't want to go
into their second quarter which is
probably a serious sales quarter for
them with this boycott still in place
and I really just don't think a leave of
absence is enough right like I don't
want to advocate for anyone to get fired
on the other hand she has really hurt
the company if they quietly sneaker back
in in June it's not going to look good
hmm
it might be a legal thing it'll be
interesting to watch it'll be
interesting to see if people keep
watching to see if she exits the company
or if she's reinstated yeah and I'm sure
they're like she's a female executive we
can't just fire her over this like that
will hurt us as well I'm scrambling to
learn more about it right now but it's
it's just such fresh knowledge uh I
don't know much to say about it yet you
know my compassion is there for this
girl but still you know when you the
market the market demands you know you
got to follow the market I feel
responsible for your decisions right so
this this news is coming out on a Friday
obviously PR 101 let the story die but
they tried this last week it did not
work they're trying it again it will not
work I'll tell you what's going to
happen Monday morning first thing there
will be a wave of political commentary
talking about just this the old rules
don't work anymore it used to be that by
Monday there was different news in the
news outlets were like what story should
we run guys and the editor comes into
the room and he's like here's a bunch of
stories that happened over the weekend
here's what we got from last night what
about that story from Friday that's old
news now there's too much online so
there's going to be a ton of people who
are going to be like here's what you
missed last weekend and they're going to
start with the biggest story Bud Light
has for for whatever reason either of
her own volition or otherwise she has
been removed from her position
so uh well next Monday morning we're
going to have news on this and
everyone's going to want to know they
need to just apologize bud just
apologize just say we're sorry for
sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney we're sorry we
won't do it again but but you gotta say
why you're sorry yeah agreed there's I I
think I think if Anheuser-Busch came out
and said we literally did not understand
the political ramifications of what this
person means to people in this country
we did not understand that that it was a
highly hyper polarizing issue we do not
here's what I'd say I'd say
first I'd say I to all of our loyal you
know Bud Light fans and drinkers I am
deeply sorry that we sponsored an
individual that was off-putting and
offensive to you we didn't mean to do
that we did not realize how strongly
people felt about this because we did
not know the context around this story
and this individual so here's we're
gonna do
we are going to rescind the sponsorship
we will strive to avoid this kind of
thing again we just want people to come
together over an ice cold brew and
celebrate with each other and if this
didn't accomplish that we screwed up
please forgive us would you buy Bud
Light if they said that yes
really absolutely I think there are
people who wouldn't I think they would
say like if you didn't know he was a
polarizing figure then you are still
lying then the damage is done yeah but
what they're playing right now is do
nothing say nothing and hope it goes
away and it's getting worse well this is
this is going to be the debate in in
conservative circles over the course of
the next week is what to do because they
fired this woman and whether the boycott
leave of absence okay leave of absence
at a corporation we know what that means
she may have said guys I'm stepping down
I I can't be involved in this right it's
possible they could have gone there and
said we want you to take a leave of
absence we don't know for sure and they
said what if she comes back like what if
they're like yeah there won't be a news
story about it if she does right they'll
do it as quietly as possible and then I
feel like conservatives are gonna have
to be like oh wait they just completely
took back the person who I assume it
okay had the most authority to let this
happen like what does that say about the
company the own I can speak for myself
here and I would not buy Anheuser-Busch
product bucks unless they not only
issued an apology that actually said we
apologize but they stated that what they
did and named what they did was wrong
and also it's not just stepped in it not
just we didn't realize it was hot button
issue but they had to say we're sorry
for sponsoring this person we're sorry
because it violates your values we
understand that we ask for your
forgiveness moving on like we're not
going to do that again that I I'm happy
to forgive them if they say that but if
they just say these if they just keep
doing the things that they're doing I'm
I'm done yeah I want to see them specify
that his audience is very young too
young and they didn't realize how young
his audience was and that there that was
a gross misconduct on their part also
it's inbev a b in Bev is the company
that owns Anheuser-Busch ABN Bev owes
the humanity and apology for for trying
to sell their beer to kids
someone said they saw a video saying Bud
Light is being sued but they are being
sued they're being sued by America First
legal for racist hiring practices
so they just opened a can of worms on
this one I think the issue is especially
with that lawsuit
Bud Light is the easiest culture War
issue for the average person there's no
brand loyalty to watered-down beer the
beer for people who don't want to drink
beer but want to drink a lot of it
there's a bunch of options for alcoholic
water there's hard Seltzer there's uh
you know other light beers I'm not gonna
I'll try not out to avoid insulting the
other beers that are doing fine because
they didn't engage in this practice but
really
I think the issue is Dylan Mulvaney is
Nails on a chalkboard to many people
that's why there's no boycott right now
over Jack Daniels or cores other
companies have done Pride promotions
Dale Mulvaney specifically is is a very
grating individual who who deeply
offends a lot of people for a variety of
reasons and I think I think uh the
transgender issue is just one small
aspect I think it's the political aspect
people hyper focus on but I think for a
lot of people it's just the I really do
think it's the narcissistic personality
disorder and I would give the prices
Right video as an example of it yeah
people were deeply bothered by Dylan
mulvania on The Price is Right and Dylan
in that video is just some guy like not
trans not expressing any ideology but
people are saying look at this Behavior
it's off-putting it's it's shocking it's
offensive it's wrong it's narcissistic
that carries through and I actually
think that Dylan Mulvaney uses trans
people as a shield for this while
simultaneously making them look look bad
like there are there are people that we
shout out periodically who are trans
themselves who are great people that we
we love and respect Dylan Mulvaney is so
long as Dylan Mulvaney is the most
prominent individual claiming to be
trans it is going to be very very
difficult for run-of-the-mill regular
trans people to be taken seriously
that's something that I find deeply
offensive that Dylan will like Dylan
Mulvaney I'll say it again hiking heels
in the forest yeah and and there are
people conservatives who've never met a
trans person who see that and they're
like that's what this is it's like no no
no hang out with Blair white Blair's
amazing super cool that does not
represent who these people are but now
YouTube is shutting down people who are
critical of that and it's almost like
YouTube hates trans people too or
they're I think it comes down to
YouTube really doesn't care they're just
like whatever makes us money I literally
don't care if Dylan Mulvaney is the
worst example of of of a person in media
who is insulting women and trans people
at the same time if it makes us money
just take the action well it's also the
phrase you said I think is key for a lot
of women and that is a very insulting
portrayal of a quote-unquote woman right
like think about the very first days of
girlhood video where sitting behind the
keyboard being like okay my first day of
being a woman I wrote an angry email
that I didn't send I cried a couple of
times I all these the very misogynistic
stereotypes of of a woman I saw that and
I was like excuse me I've been a woman
for 33 years I haven't done any of that
but you know what people who hate women
accuse women accuse women of behaving
like that what's and and what if Dylan
Mulvaney said my first day of Womanhood
I went to the kitchen made a sandwich
and did the dishes and folded the
laundry like what's the difference it's
the same stereotype insult I mean I
think part of it is like
is this the type of humor you think oh
I'm relating to you by also negging on
myself but the reality is you are not
experiencing these things it's a similar
stereotyping that bothers me when people
say oh well we have this song but he
thinks he's transgender and so we
socially transitioned him and it's like
your 12 year old is wearing so much eye
shadow I can't see his face and tons of
eyeliner like I wouldn't let my 12 year
old daughter do that you are taking
parts of being female and
inappropriately applying them to a
situation in a lot of ways but also like
the weird or like the parts of like
mature female adulthood like it just
doesn't make sense and it's okay in some
cases and not in other people no woman
that I've ever met no woman that I've
ever met behaves the way that Dylan
Mulvaney does right and no woman would
be accepted in a professional setting or
taken seriously if she behaved that way
but additionally
most trans people don't behave that way
I think one of the issues that we're
dealing with in popular culture is the
highlighting of key individuals who are
clearly bad examples there was a video
that went viral the other day of a trans
person threatening extreme violence and
that's like one crazy person you then
had the the Nashville incident you have
the extreme examples of narcissism from
people like Dylan Mulvaney and then you
have many other people that I mentioned
we know and care about who don't behave
like that at all so the the issue for me
is if someone is experiencing a mental
illness or mental disorder of any type
we want that person to get help some
people have a multitude of disorders and
illnesses in different in different
areas I'm not going to lump them all
together I'm going to say here's an
individual who is experiencing this
disorder or or mental illness and
they'll be treated in this way and then
you get a combination of a few who are
either threatening extreme violence I'm
not going to blame the person on the
left for the actions of the person on
the right you see you know you know what
I'm trying to say this distinction that
you're making is perhaps between people
who suffer from gender dysphoria versus
people who have been captured by the
ideology this is we were talking about
this right before we went on air this is
what I'm speaking about at James Madison
University on Wednesday it's why the
radical trans activists are agitating
before I get there because I'm talking
about the ideology of transgenderism
which doesn't have anything to do with
the surgeries anything to do with the
Pharmaceuticals doesn't have anything to
do with the biology nothing nothing like
that per se it's that that queer Theory
which a lot of people haven't heard
about queer theory is actually the
ideological underpinning of this
movement to capture vulnerable Youth and
the vulnerability might be any number of
things whether it's abuse whether it's
other these comorbidities whatever it
might be the vulnerability is there this
ideology comes in and says hey you don't
feel right about something you feel
unhappy the solution is to disassociate
yourself from your previous identity and
to take on this new identity and set it
all solve all your problems and I think
that the distinction that you make
between people that feel a discomfort in
their body versus people captured by the
ideology is probably true exactly Dylan
Mulvaney pushes the ideology without I I
think it's it's very very obvious if
we're talking about someone who's
suffering from gender dysphoria an
individual who looks in the mirror and
experiences anxiety and this like mental
anguish over a misalignment between
their perception and their body that's
gender dysphoria Dylan Mulvaney goes on
camera and yells about their body and
says look at my bulge and things like
that which when I've asked people who
are actually experiencing gender
dysphoria they're like a person with
dysphoria would not yell to 10 million
people look at my male body parts
because that would trigger their
dysphoria and so then there's questions
about autogynophilia and Otto
androphilia but Don Mulvaney seems to be
just an individual who desperately wants
to be famous as as uh the example being
Ellen Degeneres and The Price is Right
video so that's that's even outside of
the ideology that's Fame desperation
yeah but but I agree with you you're
right there there was a period where
many trans people were actually being
canceled by gender activists I guess I
guess we refer to as gender ideology or
critical gender Theory or something like
that there was this period where there
were a lot of trans people saying there
are only two Sexes hence if you're trans
you transition to the other yeah but the
younger generation with Z zims or and
neopronouns believe there's a plethora
of genders in which case transition can
be from any gender that's the that's the
ideological part of it right which is at
odds with someone who's dysphoric right
it's like it's like the way that I
compare it is you know take it back
three or four years ago and we saw in
our schools when it came to like the
black lives matter riots and the racial
tension that was in our country we saw
our children being taught this poisonous
stuff like if you're a white child that
you're inherently racist based on the
color of your skin if you're a black
child you're oppressed based on the
color of your skin and we all kind of
pointed to that and said wait a second
that's not right like that's that's bad
we don't want our kids being taught that
that and it took a little bit of time to
unpack the fact that this wasn't some
random poisonous ideology that this was
critical race Theory it was the
principles of critical race theory that
were being taught not being taught as
CRT but being being taught with this
ideological underpinning and when we
started realizing when those of us on
the Right started realizing that the
left said no critical race theory is
just teaching accurate history it's just
making sure that children know slavery
and we were like no no no no no critical
race theory is the grandchild of
critical theory which is a neo-marxist
ideology that exact same thing that
exact same trajectory is happening with
with queer Theory and with the with this
um epidemic of people identifying as
transgender we see this happening in
schools we're like we don't want our
kindergartners being taught about sex
about gender identity we don't we don't
want these groomer teachers we identify
that we don't like that and we're just
now as a society being like wait a
second this is not just some random
garbage that's being taught this is the
these are the outgrowth of queer Theory
it's the principles of the underlying
ideology and that's where we are right
now I want to jump to a somewhat
different but similar story or a similar
vein this is a from timcast.com Texas
passes legislation requiring 10
commandments to be displayed in every
classroom the Bill's sponsor says the
Ten Commandments are part of American
tradition under
sb15115 which just passed the Senate by
a 17-12 vote every Public elementary or
secondary school must prominently
display a durable copy or framed copy of
the Ten Commandments that is at least 16
inches wide and 20 inches tall the
display must also be legible to a person
with average vision from anywhere in the
classroom the Bill's sponsor state
senator Phil King said during a
Committee hearing on the bill that the
Ten Commandments are part of American
Heritage and that it's time to bring
them back into U.S schools oh boy wait
this is like there is no other God
before me no false Idols I mean the
second commandment basically says that
Christianity is Blasphemous you're not
supposed to worship people
are they worshiping people well this
Jesus people the Christians worship a
human and the the second command you are
incorrect that's incorrect yeah yeah you
shall not make for yourself a carved
image whether it's a human or a thing
you don't like worship Jesus was not God
yeah
and that's what they say yeah they say
he's a human that was also God but at
the same time so hypothetic nature
exactly it defies it defies the second
commandment you're not supposed to
worship other people no but he's God he
is fully God and fully human at the same
time so you worship fully God like it's
it's the the word for it is hypostatic
Union because you cannot separate the
two so worshiping Jesus I'm Catholic
that's why I know this
um worshiping Jesus you are worshiping
God he is the Son of God he is part of
the Trinity father Son and Holy Spirit
are all one three and one so it's not
worshiping a person it is worshiping God
it's worth a person a person God but you
can't spirit all at once so it is a
person no no no father Son and Holy
Spirit are all three all three it's
three and one it's the Trinity it is God
God took the form of a man
to come to Earth as Jesus Christ but you
are it's not separated it's not like oh
his body was human and his his Spirit
was God he was both fully God and fully
man so when Jesus is worshiping God I
don't want to know this is actually I
want to talk about this is a whole
different body I want to talk about the
the political uh oh yeah and
philosophical first for those that I
think we should tell you what the Ten
Commandments are so you can understand
what they're they want to put in school
I love the first one one no other gods
before me you shall have no other gods
before me two you shall not make for
yourself a carved image is that uh no
false Idols I believe yeah yeah three is
you shall not take the name of your lord
God in vain now this one's interesting
because
um what was explained to me I think this
was Prager who explained this that a lot
of people think it means you can't just
say something like oh my God because
you're using it for no reason but what
he described I could be wrong about who
if it was him or not but someone
described it as it would be like
declaring war an enemy country and
saying God wills it yes you are taking
his name to do your best editing and
that's taking his name oh my gosh these
super churches make me think it's also
like you know the phrase you know the
phrase Lord yeah Lord is actually like
not the name of God but in the old in
the Old Testament the the Jewish people
God's people believed that they couldn't
say the name actually Jews today still
like abbreviate when they say God they
put a little Dash between it because you
they couldn't say the name of God which
is Yahweh so that's it was four letters
Yahweh and so they they called it Lord
as a way of saying it without saying the
name of God because it's so he's has
such extreme Majesty that he couldn't
say the name let's read some more
because again I I'm not here to teach
you the Ten Commandments everybody but
for the context of I'll do that too this
is what they want to put in the schools
you should know this four is remember
the Sabbath day five is honor your
father and mother six you shall not
murder seven you shall not commit
adultery eight you shall not steal nine
you shall not bear false witness ten you
shall not covet so this is being passed
in Texas they want this in elementary
schools I guess the question is if if
they're putting critical race Theory
critical theory gender ideology in
schools personally I don't see any
difference and so my response is going
to be if you are trying to pass Marxism
into schools Then I then okay fine you
do that they do this where what am I
arguing can I tell you my super based
opinion on this sure okay my Super Bass
opinion on this is that this is fabulous
and that they should do it and then it
violates it violates nothing about our
our heritage of law here so truly in the
conservative movement the Republican
Party there's a difference between how
we view laws right there's like the
libertarian view that's like we should
be able to do whatever we want as long
as we don't violate somebody else's
fundamental human right government
should get off my lawn and then actual
conservatism is not libertarianism
actual conservatism is like in the in in
the style of Edmund Burke right where
it's not absolute Liberty it's ordered
Liberty ordered Liberty being defined as
more like the pursuit of justice and he
defines Justice because you're like okay
what's Justice then he defines justice
as
um original just is capital O original
justice meaning rooted in the
traditional judeo-christian morality and
this is not just something like oh okay
I'm a practicing Catholic I'm coming in
here with my religious views Edmund
Burke's philosophy is what our
constitution was based on
James Madison the father of our
constitution quoted Edmund Burke so my
belief is that indoctrination is morally
neutral it's not good or it's not good
or bad of itself and there's no such
thing as neutrality you either we are
going to be indoctrinating or they are
going to be in doctors so if we don't
have this in schools then Marxism which
I would argue is a form of like satanic
ideology then Marxism is going to be in
our school so I would much rather have
this do you agree with Ten Commandments
in schools yeah I think it's great I
mean there is an argument so I think
people misinterpret how America treats
religion right in France you have
freedom from religion so you're not
supposed to wear religious symbols in
school there's controversy over a job
providing uh kosher meals things like
that in America you have the freedom to
practice your religion however and I
think you're completely right uh we're
actually a nation that's completely
intertwined with Christianity and so
it's not wrong to have uh the Ten
Commandments in schools I mean you can
reference it in a lot of different ways
when you're teaching right like
it's also
such a fundamental part of her life that
like when we talk about uh observing the
Sabbath right like this is a case that
the Supreme Court has agreed to take on
you have this uh postal worker from
Pennsylvania who said you know I'm a I'm
uh practicing Evangelical Christian and
I observe the sabbath on Sundays and
when the U.S Postal Service started
working with Amazon they said okay but
our workers have to work on Sunday and
he said well I need a religious
exemption and eventually uh his postal
workers where he's he's based we're like
we're not going to we're gonna we're
gonna keep scheduling you for Sundays
we're not going to acknowledge that you
need a real exemption even though our
typical work week does allow for us they
said this is critical to our business
and so therefore we are allowed this is
two judges went through and said yeah
they have the right to demand that you
work and deny your religious exemption
well you have the freedom to practice
your religion right like I think that we
are so afraid of religion as a country
uh as a country that we don't learn how
to talk about it in a way that's saying
like you don't have to be a Christian
but you need to understand and
Christianity to understand the
influences it has on the country so Ian
yes or no Ten Commandments in school it
depends on how it's taught because
there's a difference between mountains
on the walls that's what they said
there's a difference between teaching
about Christianity or Judaism with this
Judaism there's a difference between
teaching about Judaism and
indoctrinating people to become Jew okay
wait wait hold on Ian a specific
question they are mounting this they
want this mounted in elementary schools
no I don't like it it needs context if
they're going to teach it they need to
teach about it and not just make people
think this is real you're like you have
to be able to choose to believe that
this is real
but all they're doing is putting it on
the wall yeah without context that makes
me nervous man you know I'm neutral on
it um I certainly understand why
Christians and Catholics and you know
whatever and and many Jewish people
probably would would be like yes this is
fantastic we should have these values
instilled to our children and you're
completely right about about an
indoctrination 100 I would prefer
The Ten Commandments over Marxism so if
someone came to me and said it's one or
the other I'd be like oh ten
commandments all the way but the systems
where they're like hey here's a really
horrible choice and you're like I don't
want that they're like okay here's a
little bit less horrible Choice want
that one instead you're like yeah yeah
it's less worse it doesn't have to be
either of them
I don't think there's anything we're not
talking I'm sorry go ahead we're not
talking about the school teaching Bible
study they're actually putting Marxism
in classroom curriculum and critical uh
critical race Theory and critical gender
theory is literally being put into math
problems this is the compromise this is
we're gonna put it on the wall and say
I'd like to see the four pillars of
Islam posted next different four pillars
of Islam our country is literally based
in this think about our laws against
homicide why do we as a people recognize
that other human beings deserve
protection under the law but like dogs
don't or something like that if you look
at morality and think about morality
there's actually no such thing as
secular morality secular morality is
just Anarchy it's just the strongest can
dominate the week the only reason that
we have order in our country right now
even as we are in a chaotic era is
because we have some acknowledgment at
the base level that people have dignity
that people have value and that's based
on that order is based on
judeo-christian values now you don't
have to practice those values in your
personal life but it is a historical to
ignore the fact that our entire system
our entire Republic is based on that
yeah is it any different than having a
dictionary in the classroom right like
if you're explaining hey fifth grader
these are what the Bill of Rights are
like here's something that influenced
that like how is having this resource
any different right like if you want to
talk about how it compares to Islam then
yeah maybe you should bring in some
tests so students can study it the truth
is Judaism is the most based religion I
think it is phenomenal because it's
about your religion your experience with
God directly you don't need a priest you
don't need any of that it's you and God
I think that is where it all comes from
all of it Christianity Islam it all
comes from Judaism but I'm following the
founding fathers saying church and state
should be separate I don't think they
ever said that that was only in one
letter that Thomas Jefferson wrote to
the Danbury Baptists to assure them that
they weren't going to face
discrimination from the government for
practicing their
relief but the the phrase separation of
church and state was never part of any
founding document and it's not part of
any philosophy about keeping morality
out of law it's only about whether the
government can either force you to
participate in religious practice or
prohibit it and I'm pretty sure there
was also conversely a Founding Father
maybe was Franklin or Jefferson that
said you need religion for a for a
society to function properly yeah John
Adams said our country was made for
moral people and no other yes I just I
see the churches capitalizing on
religion and that bothers me he's right
though we talk about us all the time so
the question I've asked is would the
United States be better or someone asked
us this would the country be better if
it was a Christian theocracy and first
of all better I guess is subjective but
if you were to talk about do we want
less crime do we want a stronger economy
do we do we want better health care if
everybody shared the same moral
foundations everyone's lives would be
better however I'm not saying which
moral foundations I'm just saying if you
had 100 million people that all agreed
communism was perfect guess what it
would work the reality is communism
doesn't work because no one ever agrees
to that great extent someone's always
got to run a system or whatever that's
why communism doesn't work but if
everybody had a simple moral Foundation
that was like the Ten Commandments or
otherwise everybody agreed that that you
know there was an afterlife there was a
God you have to be good stewards of the
earth and all that you'd have to worry a
lot less about crime
the issue is right now No One Believes
or fears that there is any consequence
to the bad things they do so we
experience more crime and Corruption
where you Liz were you taught religion
as a kid yes yeah I was raised in a I
was raised in a Catholic home and then
of course you get to an age as a young
adult where you have to decide like okay
am I going to continue in this practice
as an adult and own it versus just
participate in a family one more point
about this being in schools though and
this is really interesting if you read
the history of public schools in our
country compulsory public schooling only
became a thing in like I think
Massachusetts was the first state to do
it in 1836 and the reason that they did
that the reason they had compulsory
public schooling was to indoctrinate
children in two things in American
values and in Protestant values because
at that time in our country there were
tons of immigrants coming in our country
a lot of them were catholic immigrants
and the people in charge of our
government at the time were very
anti-catholic they were very Protestant
and they wanted to form a new generation
of children that understood that they
weren't they weren't they shouldn't
identify the country that they came from
they needed to identify as Americans so
they had to be taught American Civics
and they wanted them taught Protestant
values so the purpose of our education
system has actually always been
indoctrination we've just I mean it was
just hijacked by people who wanted to
indoctrinate the opposite of what it was
intended
I was like Rockefeller let me ask you
guys I want to read the Commandments and
and then get your opinions on it so
let's because they're because they want
to teach kids this let me ask you you
all first obviously I think the the
Christians in the room are going to have
an obvious answer uh no other gods
before me shall have no other gods
before me is that something a children
should be taught in general
uh this one makes me nervous because if
I say to you Tim there's no other God
before me and I'm reading you the
Commandment there's there can be a
possibility that you think that it's Ian
there's no other God before the ego that
is speaking the words so that's once
gets misinterpreted when the guy stands
up and says it out loud it's true that
there is one God but it is not from it's
not me it's God I think that's I think
it's unlikely that people would
misinterpret it like I think but please
stand up and take to take the credits
that's not my question my question is if
you is it is it a good thing to teach a
child about the one God
I'm not saying to accidentally say to a
kid a sentence and then walk away I'm
saying should should an adult be telling
a children
basic philosophies around the first
amendment yes first first Commandments
they crafted the ten the ten amendments
you know the ten Bill of Rights is kind
of like a I think part of it is like yes
as a Christian I think sounds good to me
and I can understand in a diverse
Society where there are different
religious views you might be concerned
like seeing there's only one Christian
God does that isolate someone else but I
think the idea behind this meaning that
there is one point of authority there's
one point of point of morality is a good
concept to teach people right it can
make them subservient to Authority so
you gotta be careful about that if I was
a kid and I saw that on the wall and I
didn't know what it meant I'd first
thing I would ask is what is God but
right but but declare I get it but I'm
trying to clarify I'm not suggesting
that I'm saying should children be
taught that there is one God and no
other God are you talking about by
public schools or in general in general
oh should children be absolutely yes
and it's what is it and you gotta
explain what it is I'm asking you in if
they should teach that in school to no
in general oh well yeah I think so
that's my that's why I like to do that I
think that's our job they could also
teach polytheism they could say which we
should yeah no I'm saying they go to
children and say did you know that Zeus
is a top Mount Olympus Zeus was a guy
that had electricity and he lied to
people and told him he could shoot I
mean I believe kids that much nut job
they're a big call living up in the
mountains that's a that's a 20 and
that's a 20. uh so here's the next one
sorry I can't get over it should
children in general be told not to
worship false idols yeah absolutely I
completely agree I think you agree to
that that was the point
yeah for sure
everyone agrees yeah yeah
conjunction with the first because you
need to know what to worship exactly and
then it actually says that it says the
first and second second commandments go
hand in hand I think the second
commandment is actually not even
necessarily a Christian it doesn't need
to be seen as a Christian specific thing
telling people not to worship false
Idols I think is a good thing Jewish
it's a Jewish thing these are all Jewish
yeah so uh uh we all agree with that and
and I'll just say I think it's because
there are bad things that will try to
trick you and deceive you and you could
be tricked into worshiping bad things
we're trying to say be careful of those
who would trick you into worship money
do not worship it bad politicians I mean
I gotta interject here and say that as a
Catholic
we look at the Bible as a whole not just
line by line like everything isn't
everything is Con is contextualized both
with the old Covenant and then the
Fulfillment to the New Covenant and the
gospels so it's not just good advice for
your life it all centers around the fact
that God has given us these laws in
order for us to better worship Him and
ultimately and this is I know the
religious point of view but it's not
just secular advice for your life but I
I think that's a actual component I
think these are to help you actually
live a better happy and more fulfilling
life if if if I were how do you define
those words like better happier and more
fulfilling do you define those as like
just here on Earth or do you find that
do you define that like okay I'm saying
it's both on Earth your goal is actually
keeping your eyes on eternity to live
this life so you can get to the next I
will say
if your view is that this is to better
worship God that is true and correct and
I would also say if you follow them your
life will be better in general and if
you're if you're tripping on DMT and you
know this stuff you'll be better off
while you're tripping so this this next
one's it three is interesting it's funny
that we're actually discussing the
philosophy of the Ten Commandments I'm
actually really excited for this you
shall not take the name of your lord God
in vain uh I'm gonna start this one
because I am not Christian I do believe
in God and my view is call it whatever
you want call it superstitious or
spiritual I am very reluctant to curse
or attempt the fates I have that I have
had many instances in my life where I
have
I don't know how you describe it I
wouldn't necessarily say it's using the
lord's name in vain but arrogance and
then I had the python in my face where
I've made jokes thinking who cares and
then experienced an uh a thing I've had
experiences in my life where I've sat
behind my computer and mocked someone
just to myself and then a week later met
them and they were the nicest person in
the world to me just ripping my heart
out I'm like I can't believe I would
think those things about this person
that was the stupidest so I look at this
I'm like call it whatever you want I
believe there is something greater than
us and I believe insulting the universe
the greater the energy or God or or that
is just I stay away from that I think
it's a bad thing I think you will be
better off if you remain humble dude
except you're except that there are
powers Beyond you like I think God
speaks to people I have when I clear my
mind and I ask tell me what to do I get
a vision of what I'm doing and but if I
went online and said God is command
commands you to subscribe to me for ten
dollars a month like that's the vein
that's absolutely that never never that
you need to follow that commandment
you're not abuse that thing I think
that's one interpretation of the word
vain I think the other part is saying
like you have to set boundaries for
yourself on what you're allowed to say
like being able to basically understand
what's inappropriate what's not
appropriate you are able to better
understand respect like this is
basically the concept of respecting
something that has more Authority and
knowledge than you do right and like
that is actually a good principle to
carry out in life so I'm just like the
principle of Salvation really it like
it's like the ultimate humility because
we are we are not worthy of even saying
his name let alone living forever with
him in eternity and experiencing his
love
right I I think except for that he came
to save us to kind of simplify why I
wanted to go through these as they're
talking about putting in schools is that
we need to teach basic philosophy on
like I think the idea that people say we
are what we are moist robots and there
is nothing Beyond light I'm like that's
the craziest thing I've ever heard like
any any degree of scientific
understanding philosophical
understanding and spiritual general
knowledge like General like I'm saying
if you're not a Christian and you just
read the Bible to better understand what
people think all of these things would
lead
I think any person who who is an open
minded is actually trying to learn they
would be like there is something truly
Beyond us at the very least and so you
got to teach kids philosophy I think I
think these are all really great this
could go in a science class because
you're talking about quantum physics I
mean then well let's let's let's look
remember the Sabbath day I'm fairly
neutral on this I mean I think a day off
is very important a day of rest
um I think it means something else to
Christians you know yeah I mean the
Sabbath is really about like meditation
family on your family meditating on the
philosophy of the things that you've
learned like I think that the Sabbath
day is something our culture doesn't
appreciate because we just see it as the
day before Monday I'm I'm gonna stop
right there and say you know what
probably the most important commandment
and I think everybody should be taught
it my view is that it is not some
arbitrary thing about God's day
necessarily it is we talk about Shabbat
and how Jewish families from Sundown on
Friday until sundown on Saturday turn
off all the devices come together and be
a family that is one of the most
powerful cultural tools
in human in human Arsenal I was sitting
in front of my computer the other night
and I heard I was I just heard this
frequency in my head like
I was like what is that noise that's my
blood pressure and when my monitor
dimmed it stopped like these these
machines are driving our minds
probably probably affecting us in ways
we don't know but my point is
remembering the Sabbath one of the
things that's breaking apart Western
Civilization is that we don't congregate
with our families and our communities
anymore yeah and to your point right to
the Sabbath Christian communities right
used to go to church together with your
family with Community then you'd go home
and you weren't a lot to work and you're
supposed to be talking to each other and
thinking about the lessons that you are
being taught in church through
interpretation through your pastor or
whatever else like it is about the moral
growth of both your family and of the
individual it's also the idea of
dedicating that day to God like it's I
agree with what you're saying that the
degradation of our society is because of
the breakdown of the family and the fact
that even when families are together
we're all on the devices that wreck our
brains but that commandment the
interpretation of that commandment is to
dedicate that day to God that like like
I go to mass every Sunday because that's
not that's that's I go to mass to
worship God the way that he laid out
that he wants to be worshiped right and
that's what it means to say okay that
day is your day it's not about me it's
not about my rest it's not about my
enrichment it's about you and so I will
stop everything I'm doing and worship
you and there's there's no there's no
question about any of the other
Commandments I think there's literally
no argument honor your father and your
mother big time it is I'm sorry if you
don't honor your father and your mother
if you don't love them and care of them
I understand that people have fights and
falling out and people but there's
always a love there for your family then
there's something wrong right like it is
it is 99.99 of humans who love their
parents I was just gonna ask Jazz
Jennings mother would you expect Jazz
Jennings to honor thy mother that's a
good question the the answer is as a
mother yes but if Jazz's mother is doing
her hateful and damaging things it's not
a mother it's not it's not an issue of
mother you know what I mean what do you
mean by Honor though it's the definition
of what do you mean by Honor are you
going to go out and you're going to ruin
the Dignity of this person that gave
life to you or are you gonna say listen
you've abused me and so with all due
respect I'm gonna separate myself from
that abuse say what was wrong and move
on like I think the word honor is pretty
important there it's because it's not a
matter of like oh you're abusing me but
you're my mother so I have to listen to
you for the rest often
you shall not murder yes that is taught
in all schools and to all children and
it's very important we do you shall not
commit adultery at least for the time
being we still have that cultural thing
but now you've got the rise of follicles
no no fault divorce it's crazy yeah
that's Reagan's fault it is you shall
not steal oh boy we're losing that one
but that's a no-brainer you shall not
the government needs to teach itself
that one oh it's for sure you shall not
bear false witness seriously don't lie
you know and then false witness means
like saying something accusing someone
else falsely like that's incredibly
important for our culture now like think
about all of the think about like the
Kavanaugh stuff and all these false
allegations that's deep things they're
false Witnesses totally yes and then you
shall not covet I I I I agree with these
and you know it's not even my my
perspective on them is not religious
yours is yeah my perspective is you will
live a better life if you understand
what these things do for humans yeah now
simply put from a religious perspective
you're saying it's to better worship God
yeah my response is okay maybe that
doesn't persuade someone but I tell you
if you follow these you'll be happy
you're healthier with a better family
better kids I think having a shared
moral understanding would make our
stronger our society stronger and I
don't need to make you go to church if
we all can agree by some basic rules and
so therefore having the Ten Commandments
in school and being like here here are
some basic rules that we all agree to
would be a beneficial thing let me let
me let me show you guys this video and
we'll jump to this segment this is a
tweet from clown world this is what
Target in San Francisco looks like let's
uh make this bigger and take a look at
this
so uh
for those that can't tell in the
immediate especially for those that are
just listening every single item in the
Target is locked you cannot take an
object shampoo razors hairspray none of
it it's all behind plexiglass and lock
yep all behind Plexiglas and locked this
is creepy huh this is cultural
degradation this is moral Decay and what
we were talking about in the previous
segment is
you know the question of what does
society be better if what what the
United States do better if everybody was
Christian the the the actual simple way
I'd put it is yes but not in my view and
I you guys probably disagree because of
Christianity but because of a shared
moral Foundation that rests on
respecting each other and Society I
actually don't disagree with you I I
mean I have never felt like I am
personally uh in charge of making
everyone be religious right it works for
me and it's important part of uh making
myself be a good person but I think
generally the the point of having a
shared value system is to have a strong
Society right and I don't think the
government should make you to church but
I do think that if you don't understand
why our rules are set up if you don't
understand the shared social contract
that we have that's based on these ideas
then you are very much likely to not
participate in society in a way that is
beneficial to your neighbors I mean if
you look at this it makes me think about
those stories have you heard of those
people who'll be like when my
grandparents went to the store they
would just like pay and then someone
would bring their groceries to their
unlocked house and put them away for
them we'd leave our doors unlocked what
are you talking about I would never do
that I would never just let some rent
but this is totally a different time
it's a time when we were a much stronger
in uh shared morality back then
everybody would meet at church on Sunday
yeah so if you broke into someone's
house are you nuts you show up to church
they're all gonna they're gonna turn at
you and they're gonna Point their
fingers at you you're ostracized so
people were like oh I I can't do that I
mean that's that's that scares me like
the the negative consequences are
massive now there's no Gatherings
there's no there's no day to spend with
your family so these people are like why
do I care if Target loses hairspray and
then the people at Target are like I
also the people who work there I also
don't care and so then you get security
guards cops and employees which is like
we literally don't care and the system
starts to break it's not just the social
contract too it's I think it's a step
further than that because it's obviously
the behavior like look at that that's
incredibly Eerie that we're at the point
in our society that that is a thing it's
also reality
like when you don't have a shared moral
fabric then you actually question what
is reality and that's where we are right
now with all of these things on on Race
on sex and gender on right and wrong on
what Justice Means all of these things
we're actually asking these existential
questions that were asked in a different
way at the beginning of our country like
what is somebody's right what is a basic
individual right what's the purpose of
government what is wrong what is what is
order we're asking all of these
questions that we haven't asked in over
250 years because we lost that moral
fabric because that was the that was the
thing that defined all of those terms
which allowed us to then build Society
on it I really think that it was this
worship of money that creeped in with
the Federal Reserve System and this
obsession with banking that happened in
like the 1500s Central Banking and stuff
because people I see them worshiping
money and it's it's a misguided love or
but if we taught the Ten Commandments
Thou shalt not covet right thou should
not come down worship false gods right
but like oh sorry to interrupting oh I'm
go ahead there's so much value to having
resources that's that's an issue it's
not money it's just you know but I I
think a component of the component of
this is the loss of community
it's really easy to be like you don't
need government when you have charity
well yeah everybody are good moral
people who agree with each other and
then everybody's living and working and
one day they see a man whose house
burned down and he's homeless and they
say we gotta help this guy and they all
pitch in and the man shakes their hand
and then the next time a house burns
down that guy joins in to help too now
neighbors don't talk to each other that
nobody likes each other and so it's all
every man for himself and they'll loot a
grocery store they don't care right they
don't know you and philanthropic uh
participation volunteer work is has been
declining rapidly for decades in America
so we say like oh we should have
Community you know non-profits or
whatever intercede and help people but
like who is running that who is
prioritizing that this is still a trend
with a lot of fundraising but typically
women make a lot of uh the majority of
philanthropic giving decisions meaning
they decide where their family is going
to donate money and that's a trend that
because a lot before women were in the
workplace they also LED their families
uh efforts towards serving the community
right whether that be through the church
through nonprofits whatever else like we
have let all of this go away because we
also destroyed the structure that was
holding it together well you know the
issue is I think you're exactly correct
the the issue is conservatives aren't
good at Art so the left makes the worst
possible interpretation of religion in
government and they make
um what's that handmaid's tale yeah and
then it's just meant to to be the most
evil interpretation of what a religious
Society is conservatives don't equally
create the inverse of the benefits or
the positives that could come with a a
shared moral Foundation
why do you think people don't like each
other
uh there's a lot of reasons people don't
like each other some people are just
they don't like each other based on
looks I believe that's rooted in uh
tribalist fear a human who is growing up
in say the 1400s lives in a small
village of 100 200 people they know that
these people they are safe with humans
are safe around those who are part of
their Community they then see another
person with a different color skin they
immediately know this person does not
live where I live they may try to take
from me steal from me or hurt me that's
I think the root of where racism comes
from is like human natural tribal fears
well we need to overcome that because
that's not the case we're all people and
I don't think someone's race is a
predominant factor in whether you can
trust them or not in fact I'm from
Chicago and I've only been mugged by
white dudes you know what I mean so like
I don't look at someone and be like I
can know everything about the person
but that's one one component one
component is
um separate moral foundations like you
think it is good to uh I don't know
let's do usury for example you come from
a society where you're like loans are
really really great it helps the you
know the systems uh Thrive and grow and
then you get some leftists who are like
usury is evil that exploits the workers
you are stealing from people now you're
at odds because of deep rooted moral
foundations so there's a lot of reasons
people hate each other right
can I add a comment yeah that your point
on Art do you know who used to be really
really good at Art and Science the
church the Catholic Church how was
Vatican 2 for you guys though I feel
like you guys gave some of it up oh yeah
that's why I said used to I think we're
reclaiming some of that like I'm sure
there's a bunch of Trad cats watching
watching your show who are like the
traditional Latin Mass who want to get
back to the beauty of that tradition the
beauty of the artwork and the cathedrals
and all of that I was just reading when
we lost some of the religiosity the
faith we lost our stronghold on on
cultural Excellence yeah the original
culture War yeah I was just reading an
article about a seminary in Cincinnati I
believe saying that they're having to
build new apartments and dorms because
they are getting Millennial men who want
to go into the priesthood after years
and years of decline I mean I think
there is a shift I think largely we've
talked about this people crave some kind
of structure and Direction you don't
actually want to be an authority in
dominated by Authority but on the other
hand people want to believe that there
is good there is evil and I think this
uh this generational shift towards queer
towards uh relationships that have fewer
structures to like I don't really think
I have to you know comply with any sort
of uh social norms at all I think that
is sort of the divisive part of the
youngest generation wokeness proves that
a lot of people crave Authority they beg
for it they want to be told what to do
and what to think and wokeness exploits
that within people some people are
leaders some people are followers and
there's no um negative to being either
some people say look I just want to work
hard I want to be a good good provide
good service to my fellow man you let me
know how I can best serve my fellow
people and that's totally fine some
people say you know what I think I can
help you better serve your neighborhood
your community and your world and those
are leaders what I'm ends up happening
is you have people who I really do think
many of them want do good easily
exploited by corrupt ideologies but
because right now you have very
liberty-minded individuals on the right
and Collective minded individuals on the
left the libertarian post post-liberal
or conservatives don't want to go to
these people and say I will tell you how
to live your life they want to say let
me give you the information to free you
and they say no I want to be told what
to do and so you're never gonna it goes
back to what I said before I know that
this is controversial even on the right
but I just don't believe that there's
any such thing as neutrality I don't
think that we can create this sort of
like even playing field this vacuum I
think something is going to fill it and
it's either going to be right or it's
going to be wrong it's either going to
be good or it's going to be evil there's
not there's not it's it the rest is just
an exercise in moral relativism but it's
it's really just right or wrong and so
if you're looking at the good of society
like we have we're so afraid as
conservatives of using the power of
government because we are limited
government government-minded people
right like we don't want to have this
huge big daddy government but because of
that we actually overcompensate and we
don't take advantage of the powers in
government that are that are justly
given to government officials by the
people so you get leftists in office
they're not worried they're they're
unconcerned with wielding their power
and yet oftentimes conservatives don't
want to do that because they're like oh
just using the power of government just
using the power of government
bureaucrats we've demonized so much when
the left does it that we don't want to
do it ourselves and I think that's
completely wrong if conservatives want
if we want an ordered Society
conservatives have to understand that
um we're going to have to fill that
vacuum with indoctrination and with with
the government a little bit or the left
is going to do it and this is a problem
I see a lot of people on the anti-woke
side they're like indoctrinations in
schools is wrong and I thought about it
I talked about this we talked we talked
about it a few months ago I'm like it
actually isn't wrong right what's wrong
is it's bad indoctrination yeah we
absolutely do want to indoctrinate
children with American values hello
children it is good to have free speech
it is good good deaf freedom of religion
it is good to have a free press it is
good to have the presumption of
innocence that's indoctrination we rely
on the parents to teach the kids so by
the time they get to the school it's not
the teacher that has to teach the kid
that it's not such a good job send their
kids to school and they're like two they
said they spend like an hour a day with
their kids families even even
well-intentioned families if your kid if
you put your kid through the traditional
tract of like daycare pre-preschool
whatever it's called like TK Pre-K
kindergarten like they're fully formed
by the education system that's the
problem if the parent isn't teaching the
kids these Ten Commandments or right and
wrong or things like that by the time
they get to school they don't know so
they'll just listen to any Authority and
maybe these people these Libertarians
are like I don't want to be that guy
because I know it's not right to take
advantage of you and someone else is
like I will don't worry about it yeah
that that's why when it comes to the
neutrality question which I think you're
correct on Ten Commandments or Marxism
I'm like man
I would much rather have the Ten
Commandments than Marxism
and I'll take it I agree that there's no
neutrality true neutral because I think
what's happening is if if it's a scale
and you've got like good and evil and
then the middle you've got neutral it's
always moving so if it's moving so fast
between the boat that it looks like it's
in the middle because it's oscillating
so quickly so you can kind of find a
balance between good and evil in within
yourself you know we have to kill
animals to eat them that's if you ever
look an animal in the eyes before you
kill it like that's a pretty evil thing
I disagree well what if it's your cat
like I mean kill your cat why would you
kill you exactly you wouldn't because
you would think it would be evil but but
you could kill your cow so like we just
kind of accept that certain evil violent
then let's say like peace and violence
we had these two things and then in the
middle there's neutral and and but it's
like we're always a balance of of both
but if you can get the balance in order
then it you can kind of seem neutral I
think but you're still both you're still
going to be one or the other at all
times I I guess I look at it a little
bit differently I look look at it as
it's a constant tug of war between Good
and Evil on that spectrum and so the
closest the closer we can get it to
permanently being up at good then when
it does have that fluctuation it's still
not quite as bad as dipping all the way
down to evil
yeah like killing a cow is not Evil
killing a cow for fun to torture the
animal is Evil killing it to eat is not
right that's the distinction humans have
had to justify that killing animals is
okay because that's how we survive I
understand it which makes which means it
literally is yeah it's fine to us but
you know yes is it to God God doesn't
want us to do factory farming I'll tell
you that I mean the Bible says it is
I asked God if he would if it would
judge me and it said for factory farming
you'll be judged I think that's a highly
biased and uh ill-informed position
maybe maybe because you need you need
like so what I what I would say to that
is I think you've probably seen a
handful of shock content videos that
make you believe farming is done in a
certain way but before you can make a
statement like that you need to actually
go to one of these so-called factory
farms and actually investigate for
yourself whether or not that what
they've told you on the internet is true
have you seen the videos of them like
picking up the little pigs and smashing
them on the ground is that noise is that
like showing a video of a murderer and
saying all humans are murderers well I'm
just asking if you've seen that video
I've seen them and those people have
seen the pools of blood and feces that
pull up once again I've also seen videos
of people of various races doing bad
things and I don't blame every person of
those races for the actions of an
individual showing me a video of one guy
bashing a pig does that make me think
all Farms are evil factory farms not all
farms
and what does factory farming mean maybe
I'm locked up in a house and you can
shove an antibiotics and you could be
referring to three Farms that's my point
so you need to you need to figure out
industrialized farming where you've
where you've have you ever gone
no and that's my point and they wouldn't
let drones fly over those things instead
of taking a strong moral position on
something you haven't investigated I've
investigated from a distance but I
haven't been on but so like I could pull
up a video where it's like the polar
bears are dying and the
environmentalists show you 100 videos of
polar bears that are gaunt looking but
they're lying all the time what they do
is they take a a a really old polar bear
on his deathbed which is normal take a
video of it and say this poor polar bear
is starving to death they're tricking
you that's what National Geographic did
you didn't make that up that's a real
thing that happened remember that very
popular photograph and video of the
gaunt polar bear that was just an old
polar bear it was an old polar bear they
knew was dying they blamed it on climate
change but it was just like no the thing
was like aged and they don't tell you
that polar bears can swim like
ridiculously far distance they're almost
aquatic mammals my point is this I agree
with you it's bad when you see a video
of a guy torturing animals and stuff and
I blame that person for torturing
animals I don't know if if it's
indicative of all large-scale farming
it's the antibiotics that they use in
Mass though like they'll hit things with
antibiotics but before they're sick just
so they don't get sick and then that
makes people sick but that's not
torturing an animal that's that's like a
human error you know what I mean they'll
have like mastitis on the cow nipples
because they suck they put they hook
them up to machines and they just 24 7
they're just kind of I don't know how
have you ever gone to a dairy farm
uh no I've been to like eight and I've
never seen that which ones I went
California I went to three different
ones I've been to a few well I went a
bunch throughout California I've been to
uh some in Tech I think Texas I don't
know if there's a beef that might be
beef cattle so uh We've out here the
Farms don't have any of that and we've
been to like three or four of those so
my shout out to all the organic farmers
out there but this isn't real people
don't people don't understand this like
I was confused by this when I went to
the first dairy farm ever in California
and there was no fence
and the cows were all eating and I said
what if the cows leave and the farmer
goes where would they go and I was like
well I don't know like what if they just
like wander off and he goes but where
and I'm like a random Direction and
leave and he goes but there's no food
there and I'm like are you saying cows
won't leave and he goes
yeah why would they leave the food's
right here and I was just like and he
was like you ever hear this thing till
the cows come home
cows aren't gonna go wander off and die
in the woods bro you didn't say bro but
like that's the idea like you think cows
are so dumb they're gonna be like might
as well just go die no they're not like
looking to take a vacation
Trail and try to like build up
civilization I heard there's great
surfing if I just keep but so uh what he
pointed out was the milking stations the
cows choose to go into because they're
uncomfortable right they build a bunch
of milk up and the cows are like and
they walk in and the Machine then milks
them and the cows walk back out and
start eating again and the one thing I
could say is probably sad or cruel is
the taking of the calf from the mother
oh my God it's brutal but I also don't
think it's evil I think
lions eat animals cats eat animals the
the world as it is as nature is is that
is it is it evil when a rabbit eats a
flower no it's destructive it's not evil
I don't think the word evil is really
even that valuable these days I I
actually wouldn't even agree that it's
destructive the rabbit eats the flower
and then turns the flower into more
rabbits that's creative it destroys the
flower to create yeah but it says
creation and destruction you know we're
just the flower serve its ultimate
purpose by feeding the rabbit and
creating more rabbits that is when
people like animals are here otherwise
we just Wilt and die and then it would
just go back in the soil and actually
some of the seeds actually evolved
specifically so that through the
digestion of the animal it sprinkles the
seeds around meaning many of these
plants actually do want to be eaten
I mean fruits exist for a reason the the
plant will drop something that is full
of sugar so that something will eat it
and carry its seeds and help it
propagate
yeah man I'm concerned with factory
farming High use of antibiotics feces
and blood family in the environment I I
get all of that secrecy but I think I'm
concerned that's propaganda
antibiotic overuse
based on on big food and big Pharma and
I think our overuse our societies
overuse of antibiotics is like wrecked
our guts and caused a lot of chronic
health conditions and that because
there's incredible profit motiv on both
sides like from big food and then big
Pharma to like circulate this like
problem solution problem solution like I
agree with you on that I I don't I don't
know a lot about the factory farming
stuff that you guys were talking about
but just the widespread use of
antibiotics to prevent problems like
that's objectively a problem right yeah
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends if you really do like it and
become a member at timcast.com by
clicking join us and support our work
let's read what you got Jake Moore says
hey guys you should look into the auto
key card federal case that ended today
basically people were convicted of
trafficking machine guns said machine
guns were metal cards with drawings on
them yup so his guy the guy's name is I
think it's Matt Hoover and he had a
YouTube channel and they had these metal
cards with drawings on them if you took
those things and you cut out those
drawings stencils and then did something
with them it would turn the gun into a
machine gun or something so they said
selling them in fact was selling
conversion kits which is illegal and
then like I guess the
that the parts were also bottle openers
or something like that like it
technically could be a bottle opener but
could also be used to convert a weapon
this is insane because they were selling
basically metal cards with drawings on
them and they called it a conversion
starter kit so the question that is if
you post an image of that online are you
posting a diagram to construct a can
like where is the line well the
government uh I think was like eight
women four men said yep you did it
you're going to jail
crazy
that's actually a huge huge problem
because you can't sell a piece of metal
with lines drawn on it that's so weird
I'm concerned with creating a black
market of information let's just never
forget that the director of the ETF was
like I'm not a Firearms expert or like
this is what they do this week like
remember when the 3D gun blueprints went
around online and it was like literally
just a blueprint a piece of paper and
they were like no you can't you can't
let that circulate the Market's still
huge it's just the media is not talking
about totally and so because the 3D
computers are better now yeah it's for
the inside it creates a black market of
information it doesn't mean that people
who want to use it aren't going to be
able to find it it means that
law-abiding people are going to stay
away and it's a law you can't enforce
which makes a mockery of the system that
makes the law all right Brandon Allen
says so much long blonde hair on timcast
tonight I like it especially Ian you
should see Tim take the beanie off then
again it's like he's like a mermaid you
guys ever watched Adventure Time
when Finn he wear yeah he takes it off
in big golden blonde hair comes up
let's see what we got here um I say
Federal he says if Milo is actually
there ask him if he's ever been to
transnistria to see his creepy daily
Stormer friends and it's really just
about the age of consent oh yikes uh
Milo was supposed to be here um but he
couldn't come
but I don't know why so uh we had him
booked but um I don't know he i i i a
second information he had something with
his eye where it was like I was gonna
tell him I was gonna call myself my Ian
milanopoulos yeah that's what it was his
hair is not as long and blonde though so
I feel like this was better yes this is
definitely better grappi says that UFO
needs to be peckable at some point we
mean like we should put a UFO in the
chicken coop it'll just pop off that'd
be so funny
David Toronto says not everyone is
deserving of Love Ian hmm that's an
interesting question do you think
everyone's deserving of love I think the
answer is actually yes oh of course yes
I think yes even Eve like
it's tough because I know there's some
really depraved and evil people out
there but I would refer to God's love
yeah you know maybe not humanly but
something Beyond you know self-love you
know yeah I don't think everyone's
deserving of trust and I think people
mix up love and Trust right like you can
love someone and know better than two
tries you can also love someone and send
them to prison loving someone means that
you like
respect their dignity like human to
human love I mean respect their dignity
and their rights it doesn't mean that
you let them get away with stuff or like
them like like and love are very
different things but I I look at it this
way let's say someone uh is an evil
murderer he targeted children kill the
kids
I can certainly understand humans saying
I will not give love to you but would
you think that that person is still
deserving of God's love
yeah I mean the the example if someone's
on if someone's on death row like people
pray for death row inmates all the time
that is love praying for them it doesn't
mean that they should be let out it
doesn't mean that they shouldn't suffer
the consequence of their action like but
that is love I think that's very
different than being like friends with
someone or even liking someone like you
can show someone love God's love because
like in the whole Christian worldview
right like none of us are deserving of
God's love and he loves us anyway and
that doesn't mean that we aren't bound
to follow Like rules and consequences
but that kind of like we order our
society after but yeah I think people
all people are deserving of love
right on all right let's see we got
trash Panda says stand to your ground
don't buy Bud unless they apologize but
if they mean to enter the culture War
let it begin here oh
I I will take an apology that if that
statement they put out if they included
at the beginning we are sorry for the
sponsorship of Dylan Mulvaney I just say
okay yeah I'll buy some bud right now I
love Dylan I love that he's culture
jamming and pissing people off I love it
he is he's a master if it wasn't
targeting children I might agree oh I
can't stand no that should be condemned
every every step of the way I I like
culture jamming I like people who you
know as I say figuratively throw up high
I think Elon Musk is a master of it but
you got to leave the kids out of it man
like let kids be kids Let Them Girls let
them learn it's tough because kids are
watching this right now so you just
gotta be judicious and I don't think
this is a big conversation stuff when
you're alone and you have 100 million
followers when it's just you and you
can't relate to anyone
Let's uh let's read some more
what do we got uh Scott Smith says Tim
and crew don't be surprised if the next
moving goal post
techopoly policy no dissenting
advertisers here's some Monopoly monies
towards Freedom stand thank you sir do
you mean no uh dissing advertisers no um
no descending Advertiser sounds like
you're saying you can't advertise that
you're upset with YouTube whereas I
think you mean no insulting or uh
dissing advertisers
no insulting advertisers
that's interesting I loved it when
Michael Bloomberg sponsored my channel
yeah he was dumping so much money into
YouTube this was a 20 this is the 2020
cycle he was in the primary in 2019 or
whatever and uh and early 2020 and
people was it 2020 I think I don't know
when when yeah he ran in 2020 yeah and
people were like Tim I'm seeing a whole
bunch of Bloomberg ads on your videos
and I don't like him and I'm like I'll
take his money I don't care dude there's
Bud Light videos Bud Light ads all of
your videos like right away yep where
are the RFK Junior ads that's all I want
to know we gotta start sharing this
stuff RFK Junior Vivek ramaswamy or
ramashwami is Toronto Trump will call
d99id says Tim Needs to watch the anime
Dr Stone Humanity gets fossilized for
3000 years and rebuilds from scratch
with modern day knowledge speechless
I've seen it I've recommended it it's
really cool
um it's this really smart dude Humanity
gets fossilized some people don't
thousands of years later everyone's kind
of like tribal level intelligence but
this one dude is super smart and correct
me if I'm wrong because I haven't seen
enough of it but he basically I don't
know why they got fossilized maybe
that's been revealed and you guys know
they turned us down but he was so smart
he like did something that as soon as he
turned to stone it triggered the events
by which it would defossilize him
because he's a genius anyway the story
is he's like okay we're gonna make a
cell phone here's what we got to do and
then they talk about all the things you
have to get in order to make a cell
phone he like makes vacuum tubes and
glass and it's it's really cool it's
like a science show for kids but it's
how how would you make something if you
were in the middle of the woods you know
what's that movie where they are like
Frozen for a hundreds of years and then
everyone's really stupid and they wake
up idiocracy I feel like there's a
similar correlation between these story
lines would you put yourself in
cryostasis Liz to wake up in a thousand
years no yeah you're living for this
life I'm living with my eyes on eternity
or at least that's what I try to do yeah
and people need to realize this too if
you if yeah would you do it no I got too
much to do now maybe if I was older
here's what would happen
imagine if someone from the year 1800
appeared right now in this time they
would not know how to communicate they
wouldn't know how to move from place to
place they'd be going around asking for
a horse and people think we don't have
any it's like well how am I supposed to
get around cars what is that and how
does it work I have no idea how do I
learn about what's going on in the world
the internet do you have a newspaper no
we don't
so if you went uh 100 200 300 years in
the future you'd be like I need to get
online and figure out what's going on
and there'd be some kid going online
what if they took you to an underground
bunker and there was always using we are
from the future and we need to put you
in cryostasis because we need you in a
thousand years would you do it
I don't know dude
they if if it'd be really hard to
convince me that was reality
so probably not I'd be like I don't know
you we know you're gonna say this I
trust you that's why we have this and
you'll be like what is it whatever it
was more I just I don't think there's
any way to actually convince someone
that something is that fantastic
Elizabeth they told us he was going to
say that that's what the history books
say he said he was going to say and they
wouldn't be able to do anything about it
all right let's read some more
Killian Chapman says my favorite beer
was Modelo before the stunt I will admit
that I didn't realize that Modelo was a
b product but after I figured out I
haven't had it since
uh well I think it's that Anheuser-Busch
owns like half of it or something like
that I'm not entirely sure but I think
Modelo is is partially owned whereas
like Anheuser-Busch has products they
literally own and I you want to look it
up real quick I'm pretty sure it's half
owned I think that's the issue
all right
Cody Schofield says I would exclusively
buy Bud Light if they gave out an
apology commercial frame by frame just
like the BP South Park commercial oh
hands down if they apologize like a good
strong apology like Dylan Mulvaney we
believe is like over the top and it was
wrong of us to do this we're sorry we
think kids should be kids we shouldn't
have like and they really hammer it on I
would this house would be an
Anheuser-Busch house we would we would
buy all their beers for all of our
guests and be like they did right by us
if they simply apologize I will buy some
beers it looks like Modelo is owned by
inbev so it's hydrate or half uh that
says it's the parent company oh okay
well there you go I'm worse than I
thought that's a company that owns
Budweiser all right surprised they
didn't like have Dil mulve any sponsor
their Seltzer right like something that
made more sense something that almost
made sense I'm not sure I would be okay
with it because again the of the
audience's age but like still why did
you say sacrifice yourself such a Nutty
thing I just don't understand how this
conversation went down Mark uh daddy
says Tim team up with Jeremy Sydney
lives in other craters and take legal
action against YouTube about taking down
the videos we viewers will pay the legal
cost it's not about winning the case
it's about publicity I don't I don't
know if I agree with that statement
actually I think actually there's an
argument to be made for winning the case
um we do not break the rules that
YouTube has we have a contract with
YouTube YouTube has come to us we have
come to them and we've agreed if I
provide X they will provide y we make
content that appears on YouTube YouTube
sells ads against that content it's a
mutual partnership contract act like any
other business contract YouTube told us
however if you do these things then we
will take action against you and
negatively impact your your work
relationship with us YouTube sent a
notice to Jeremy and Sydney saying we
think this violates our policy so we're
taking it down whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa hold on if I have a contract with
you that says you will deliver me Oak
and not Birch and then you come to me
and say you know what I think that might
be Birch so I'm not paying you
you can't do that you have a contract
you will get sued so there is a strong
argument to be made that YouTube must
either act 100 in aligned with what
their policies are or not at all
that is to say YouTube must definitively
come out and say outright yes this did
breach the contract here's why and the
reason why I think they don't do that we
saw it with
um Alex Berenson when he sued Twitter
they told him here are the parameters by
which you will be banned and then when
he got banned outside of those
parameters they were in breach of
contract he won
if they come to us and say overtly you
did breach the contract I can then argue
prove it in court because we have a
contractual agreement to make money for
each other and you are in breach of
contract now and then they'll have to
justify it they'll say yes we can prove
it the answer is they can't prove that
we did anything wrong we didn't we were
talking about what someone else said we
did not break those rules but they need
to remove the content because Budweiser
is mad I think they're in a dangerous
territory where they're opening
themselves up to litigation it would be
really interesting to enter a suit in
that capacity because there may be a
temporary injunction injunction on
removal of content in that period
meaning if Jeremy Hambly files a lawsuit
against YouTube saying that this was a
breach of contract a judge may say until
the resolution of this case you are you
are you are blocked from further
removing content from Jeremy Hambly
that could be interesting
yeah
yeah until the resolution of the case
that'd be super interesting because
that's what our notice said said you may
be in in violation and they they
intentionally want to be big just like
they're intentionally vague with their
standards like I do the same thing I
don't I'm not trying to be bombastic I'm
not trying to to violate their terms of
service I understand I don't agree with
the terms that they set that doesn't
mean that I'm going to go in there and
violate them because I don't agree like
I know what their terms are I try to
work around it but but it's not even
that it's like when talking about these
issues in particular
the spirit of the rule the intent of the
rule is they don't want someone coming
on and being extremely in like
insightful to call someone a derogatory
slur or or deride them intentionally to
cause pain
no they would prefer that they're
insightful
right in the correct way and so but the
way I referred was be academic right
when we make an argument about gender
ideology it's not because we hate
anybody it's because we love them when
there are kids who are suffering from
something we want to help them in the
proper way so when you look at what
happened in Europe they abandoned the
child sex change surgery and and puberty
blockers because it was hurting them so
out of a place of love we are saying we
need to stop hurting these kids we've
seen the evidence out of Europe they
shut down Tavistock the Scandinavian
countries have abandoned this it clearly
is causing more harm than good for the
sake of the betterment of these children
and for these individuals we want them
to get better treatment if YouTube
strikes you for that now they're in
breach of contract hands down hands down
so I think any time someone gets a
strike they need to file a lawsuit
immediately file a lawsuit and just say
look we have a contract you've breached
it
if the court agrees that we are wrong we
accept those like it's up to a judge to
decide but imagine a world we're in this
world right now where
you sign up for YouTube It's a mutual
contract YouTube needs our content in
order to sell ads we need their ads to
generate Revenue we need their platform
to host our content it's a mutual
agreement
for YouTube to just say we're going to
breach your contact contract outright
good luck that's not how the the
business World works you can't do that I
haven't read the entire terms do they
have a clause where it says they can ban
anyone at any time for no reason yes but
I I don't believe that actually is uh
will fly it just seems so illegitimate
the reason if it's in writing it seems
ridiculous so that was the issue with
Alex Berenson I think it was because
they said here's what constitutes a
violation of our rules at that point it
sort of I could be wrong but I believe
that nullifies that we can do whatever
we want whenever we want because there's
an expectation among the individual that
the working agreement does not mean you
will arbitrarily ban someone it means
you will only be banned for a reason and
then they have to specify what that
reason is one of the reasons Twitter
would often say your banned for blank
was because they knew if they gave a
reason they could be challenged in court
more easily I don't think not giving a
reason is going to fly I think we saw
Alex Barrington one he got reinstated
because of it I mean isn't that why they
use these terms like hate speech and
harassment because they can just they
can just Define that on the fly as
anything they want so they can actually
Target People based on their opinions
and their ideology or their dissent from
the prevailing radical leftist ideology
and they can just say oh we've decided
that this is harassment because it hurts
somebody's feelings we've decided that
this is hateful because we think your
views on sex or gender are not what we
think they should be so we think it's we
think it's targeted at someone
individually intentionally vague but I
got one for you uh
if the videos where we highlight what
Matt Walsh says constitutes a violation
because we play what Matt Walsh says if
a video of Donald Trump making a
statement constitutes a violation
because a news Outlet I think this
happened to the hill arising they showed
a clip of Donald Trump talking who
talked about the election 2020 so they
took the clip down that's really
interesting because David Pacman had
Mike Lindell on his channel and Mike
Lindell said all of the exact same
things and there was no enforcement
action proving YouTube is breaching its
contract with the hill Rising for this
removal by allowing some people to
display that same content and others not
to so it's time to start filing those
lawsuits to to be like look I don't hate
YouTube I want you to be better but
YouTube If we have an agreement and you
breach that I'm sorry that's not legal
that's a civil tort violation and and it
needs to be adjudicated
it's it's not gonna be be solved until
people actually file the paperwork and
if it turns out legally we're in the
wrong oh well then so be it but you have
to file in a court and have a judge
decide
we'll see what happens
all right what do we got
let's grab some more Super chats Garland
says please Tim send Ian to Summer Bible
camp this is the last Super Chat you
will ever get from me look me up in a
I'm a whale I'm atheist but Ian's
ignorance on faith is so cringe it's so
jerkish you need a button to tell tell
him to Cork insulting people
you know perhaps a little heart harsh
garhant but I I do think Ian you often
have a bit of invective in your speech
when you're talking about religion tell
me more about that well I think when you
bring it up you you bring things up in a
way that seem to be intentionally
insulting to Christians instead of being
academic and asking them you say
outright you're worshiping a false idol
Jesus is not God instead of saying I
never flipped over one of Joel Osteen's
tables
sure but I'm saying like that's what
Jesus did he went into the the church
where they were selling things and he
flipped a table over because he was like
this is not about money this is about
God maybe the appropriate way is to say
okay I'm not a Christian but you're
Catholic how do you explain to me the
difference between worshiping the human
of Jesus and God because I don't
understand right that would be a more
respectful way to to broach the subject
in which you're not familiar as opposed
to saying no you're wrong you know what
I mean not I'm not I'm not saying that
example specifically right it's probably
like the humility of me just becoming a
student of religion would be way more
effective I think I haven't insulted by
you yeah I mean if you want my perfectly
honest analysis I thought you didn't
know much about what about the Ten
Commandments or much about Christianity
so it was like the absence of
information that you were making a uh um
a conclude drawing a conclusion that was
just kind of wildly incorrect but I
didn't I didn't feel animosity and then
I just felt like a little ignorance
about the topic I think we're having
Kirk Cameron on at some point I could it
could be totally wrong about that and I
don't want to say that because like he's
like he's such a big famous guy and I'm
kind of like maybe I shouldn't say that
as I know for sure but I'm really I'm
hoping that's the case like I don't know
that'd be interesting I normally don't
like to mention guests but I think he
would be he he would be one of the best
but let me just double check and um does
he bringing Candace Cameron that's what
I was wondering I just want to know
let's do it part of being ignorant is
like if you're in a conversation with
someone and you're ignorant and you're
humble about it it never really bothers
the other person because they can tell
and it's like let's just talk about it
and we'll learn together but when people
are listening and they can't respond
it's not then they'll be like ah that
ignorant guy I'm not able to say that
just listen and I can't because he's on
TV and so I understand the frustration
from people on the other side of the
screen I actually think it's one of the
nicest things that we have totally lost
in our culture to be able to sit down
and be like well listen our world view
is pretty different right like me being
a Catholic Christian you not
um that changes the way that we view
almost every situation from each other
but to be able to actually sit down and
have a conversation that's what's been
completely lost in our culture not just
religiously but politically where like
you know I'm going to James Madison
University instead of the people you
know who disagree
he is not I don't know why I think
Cameron can you hear us I need you to
come on the show now now maybe he will
bring your sister I wonder about the
Hallmark Channel I'll just I'll just say
this right now I thought I thought we
may have book booked him but you know
like Kirk is probably like someone's
heading up or you're going on Tim so
it's like I know you were talking about
uh but hold on just just just wrap that
up he's not on the schedule I wish he
was in the schedule Kurt Cameron we
desperately need you to come so that you
me and Ian can sit down and you can
explain things to Ian beautiful let's do
a culture War podcast in the day and
then if you want to stick around we'll
come on the show on Friday night and
talk we should we should bring your
sister because we've got stuff to talk
about with her and bring your sister
Candace I love you Full House one of the
best shows of all time
oh yeah she's she's a delight
um no my thought was just I'm totally
thrown you off by a random calls no I'm
just doing like a hard a hard transition
there
um I appreciate having conversations I
think like listen like I said I'm going
to this college campus and instead of
people coming and saying like coming up
to the microphone there's a little Open
Mic at this event it's a public event
open to anyone instead of coming up and
being like Liz you say XYZ and I think
you're wrong because of ABC and like
trying to destroy my argument like come
and try to destroy my argument like we
should be having these debates but we've
gotten to a point in our culture where
they say that my opinion is violence
that it's harming them right and that
they're unwilling to even engage like I
think this is the most fun thing ever to
be able to sit here and be like yeah we
mutually respect each other we're having
conversation about very different World
Views let's understand let's argue let's
even tell each other like no you're
totally wrong and here's why and still
no animosity like that's actually what
makes a civilization because everyone's
not going to be of one mind on every
issue but talking about it is like great
I got a good one Milo Hoffman says you
are arguing about the wrong thing Public
Schools should not exist government has
no more business running our schools
than they do running our churches we
need separation of school and state
agreed yeah sure but in the reality they
do currently exist how do we do with
them I do like I agree though by the way
I know that this is like even beyond
what base conservatism is I said this to
my I said this to my producer the other
day I was like
um pretty soon I'm gonna come out and
say we shouldn't even have public
schools and all the conservatives are
going to try to distance themselves from
me and five years from now they're gonna
be like Oh that girl was right
um because I mean what are they doing
they're just they're just indoctrination
centers but indoctrinating bad stuff
so uh loath there Mordred shirk media
says Tim I loved your content but I view
Marxism and Christianity Christianity as
hypocritical and very destructive I
think Marxism is I actually think my
view of Christian I'm not a Christian
and uh my view of Christianity
Christianity is
let me just I'll tell you the same old
story I've told a million times Sodom
and Gomorrah if there's but one
righteous person right that is the root
of the presumption of innocence so my
view of Christianity is that we have our
founding fathers in this country crafted
a set of morals and guidelines rooted in
Christian Christian morals and ethics
that we all basically agree are really
really good
I think you got to watch out for
charlatans you got to watch out for
people who are like I'm a good Christian
and they're actually like evil
narcissists who are trying to accumulate
power but Marxism
is just inherently bad and the radical
theories critical theory critical gender
Theory they're all really really bad
divisive they they breed hate and
animosity and the moral framework of uh
of Christianity is actually something
most people would agree on even Bill
Maher he doesn't he may not know I'd
love to have a conversation with him but
like I mentioned the presumption of
innocence literally came from the Bible
Blackstone was inspired by this
blackstone's formulation Ben Franklin
said it later you don't have to believe
in all intents of Christianity to
recognize the moral framework there has
benefited us greatly and created
individual individual rights uh The
Pursuit of Happiness the the
self-governance I mean tremendously
amazing things so it's natural law what
you're talking about is natural law like
when I said Edmund Burke's philosophy
underpinned our constitution
Constitution was built on on on British
law right like on on English common law
which was rooted in natural law
yeah I think we have to get back to that
it's what uh Prager called Cut Flower I
think he called it with a cut flower uh
politics or ideology I always get it
wrong but he basically described you
have this beautiful flower and you snip
it from its roots and hold it and show
off how beautiful it is and then in a
few days it's dead because you've cut it
from its roots and Our Roots come from
this uh judeo-christian moral framework
that um I think are beneficial I don't
think that mindless collectivism is a
good thing I think you can find that
anywhere I think you can find good
churches and bad churches I think you
can find charlatans and Christianity who
pretend to be good moral Pious
individuals when they're actually just
trying to steal from you and then I
think people often will look at the
worst and assume that of all people so I
don't like to do that I like to judge
people as an individual someone who is
Christian that doesn't inherently
instantly mean I think they're a good
person and I would love to have you on
the show Joel Osteen I mentioned
flipping a table over and using
um
what Jesus did in the temple so like I
know you have a multi-million dollar
giant mega church where you make I don't
know how many hundreds of millions of
dollars per year but I still want to
talk to you about God
well right on uh I think it would be
cool we should definitely try and reach
out to Kirk Cameron's people and do a
culture War podcast discussion maybe
even Sheamus so uh we'll wrap there if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show become a member
at timcast.com you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast uh Liz do I shout
anything out yeah thanks so much for
having me you guys have been great you
guys if you're in the area the event at
James Madison University on Wednesday
the 26th is at 6 p.m you can go to
lizwheeler.com to get your tickets
support if you can't be there in person
uh watch but subscribe to my show if you
would too at lizwehler.com or wherever
you listen to your podcast thanks so
much for having me this has been great
yeah it's been cool to have you on I'm
Hannah club remlo I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should go to timcast.com
click on the read tab you can see all
the work from me from Chris Bertman from
all of our awesome journalists uh if you
want to follow along with news on social
media you should follow at timcast news
on Twitter and Instagram it's excellent
if you want to follow me personally you
can find me on Instagram handclare.b and
Twitter at HC brimlow thanks so much
guys thank you uh you can follow me Ian
crossland.net Ian cross on anywhere on
social media I'll be uh take human
actiontour.com take human actiontour.com
I'll be there April 29th that's next
Saturday in Austin so hope to see you
there Liz thank you for talking about
neutrality this is going to be has me
thinking deeply because I I all I've
been stuck in this oscillating evil good
mind but I think you might be right that
you can oscillate above so thank you
thank you I'll be thinking a lot about
that uh yeah this is great I really
enjoyed it and make sure people want to
follow you on Twitter it's Liz
underscore wheeler it is it is Liz
underscore wheeler all right uh hey I'm
Kellen I do post-production for timcast
and fill in for search on Fridays follow
me at Kellen PDL and this was a good one
I always like when the religion stuff
comes up so yeah I have fun all right
everybody thanks for hanging out we'll
have Clips throughout the weekend and
then we'll see you all on Monday